The sun’s gone bad!
People and animals are melting everywhere!
The world is coming to an end and there’s
nothing I can do about it!
Will I be able to find food?
Will I be able to defeat or avoid the horrific
flesh monsters all around me, or the desperate
and hungry survivors left in this terrible
new world?
Keep watching and find out.
Can I survive 100 days in SCP-001 - When Day
Breaks!?
Hey folks, it’s ya boy, Kyle.
You probably know me more for gaming videos
than post-apocalyptic vlogs, but hey, I’m
a versatile guy, and I think I might go insane
from the fear if I don’t talk to somebody
about all this craziness.
If you’re alive and seeing this right now,
well, congratulations, you’re probably doing
a lot better than most people here, if you
can call them “People” now.
But if you’re seeing this a few years in
the future, like, I don’t know, you woke
up from a ten-year coma like Rick from The
Walking Dead and you’re wondering what the
hell happened to Planet Earth…
This video is probably gonna answer a lot
of your questions.
First thing’s first, whatever you do, you’ve
gotta stay away from the sun.
It touches you even for a second, you’re
dead, or worse.
Welcome to Day One of the End of the World.
For all of you who are still in a solid state
of matter, you’re probably wondering how
I’m still alive, too.
Chances are, it’s for the exact same reason
you are: Sheer, dumb luck.
I was down here in my gaming basement when
day broke, just level grinding when my TV
got taken over by those SCP Foundation people,
telling us that the sun’s gone evil for
whatever reason and now we’ve all gotta
stay inside.
Hell, if I was up there making myself a sandwich
or grabbing another can of Mountain Dew, I’d
be a freaking puddle right now.
It’s funny, my mom always told me spending
all day indoors was bad for me.
I’ll have to mention that to her, if she’s
alive…
Point is, the world has gone to hell in a
handbasket and I’ve now got only one objective:
Survive!
I’m gonna see if I can survive the horrifying,
post-apocalyptic world of When Day Breaks!
For this first day, I’m just gonna hunker
down.
I kinda hope this is just a dream…
Day 2.
Alright, I’m up and at ‘em, baby.
Sadly, I can now report that this isn’t
a dream.
This really is our horrible new reality.
It’s the sun’s world, and we’re just
living in it!
I’ve been spending the last several hours
just waiting for nightfall outside.
Against all odds, the internet and the power
grid haven’t gone down yet - Guess whatever’s
wrong with the sun only affects people and
animals, not objects.
Thank heaven for small mercies, right?
People on Twitter have been live-posting their
situations out there, sharing advice on how
we might all be able to stay out of the sun
and survive this whole crazy thing.
And hey, unless they’re dead or full of
hot air, maybe those “SCP Foundation”
people know something about what’s going
on here.
If we really can get to their buildings, maybe
we can figure out how to reverse all this
mess.
Maybe.
For now, I’m just gonna focus on staying
alive.
Hopefully night hits soon, I really need the
bathroom…
Oh boy, it’s Day Three and new issues are
starting to pop up.
I’ve been heading upstairs to go to the
bathroom, but while I don’t want to be crude,
I’m running low on toilet paper and it’s
starting to become a problem.
I ran out of my last roll a few days ago,
and now, I’m starting to go to my bookshelves.
I had a few newspapers left that I tore up
and used for toilet paper first.
They weren’t exactly comfortable, but hey,
you need to make do.
But without toilet paper and without newspapers,
I need to figure out what my favorite and
least favorite books are.
I’m starting with the prefaces of all the
books - seeing as I don’t generally need
to re-read them.
They’re expendable, you know?
A lot of these books I haven’t read since
I was fifteen, so maybe those’ll be the
ones.
I can’t make my mind up on whether I’m
gonna use the Harry Potter books or the Percy
Jackson and the Olympian books first.
Uhhh, let me know what you think in the comments,
I guess.
I need to go to the bathroom.
Day Four, and now, I’m trying to figure
out how to pass the time.
As you already know, I’m an avowed, life-long
gamer.
So, while the electricity and the internet
still work, I’m gonna keep gaming to pass
the time and keep my all-too-precious sanity.
I still have no intention of going out there,
even at night, but it’s left me feeling
kind of stir-crazy.
I want to walk around the city again, I want
to go for a drive and feel the breeze in my
hair.
But seeing as I can’t do that without experiencing
a truly horrifying transformation, I’ve
been spending a lot of time on GTA V online.
Guess we’ll never get GTA 6 now, what a
bummer.
Still, these last few days it’s felt more
like Los Santos has been my home than where
I actually live.
There were even a few other people on the
server.
I don’t know about you, but I take some
comfort in that.
Hey folks, I’m back, thankfully.
Welcome to Day Five.
We’ve still got electricity, thankfully,
hence why you can still see this.
I haven’t heard anything from my family.
I don’t wanna assume the worst, but…
It’s probably just best not to think about
it.
I’ve been heading up and downstairs to grab
more food at night.
You’re probably wondering, “But Kyle,
why don’t you bring it all downstairs to
save going up altogether?”
To which I’d say, I don’t have a fridge
downstairs, smart-ass.
But I’m starting to realize food is gonna
be a real issue here.
It’s kinda stupid, now I think about it
- In all the zombie movies and TV shows I
used to watch, it was all bullets and baseball
bats.
Killing your way through all those undead
freaks and worrying about the rest later.
Guess they don’t want you to think about
how you’re only ever a couple of weeks away
from starvation, kinda ruins the badass post-apocalypse
power fantasy.
I only have a couple days worth of food left
here, and after that, I’m gonna need to
go out and search for more.
Or I’m gonna need to relocate.
I don’t feel comfortable here anymore, y’know?
Early on, I thought when you got exposed to
the sunlight, it just killed you.
But no, it’s worse.
You keep living, you’re just changed into
one of those…
Things.
These last few days, I’ve looked out the
windows when I’ve come up at night for food.
I see them sometimes, slithering in the yard
or down the street, these things that used
to be people.
I wonder if they’re people that I knew once,
before all this, then I try to shove that
thought out of my mind.
Freaking myself out about all this doesn’t
help, I know that much.
I just keep thinking about how they move,
with this weird kind of… purpose?
Like they’re searching for something, but
what could they be searching for?
I’m just gonna go and get more food.
We’ll speak again soon.
Stay safe, whoever you are.
Welcome to Day 6.
It’s nighttime now, and I’m heading out
for the first time.
I keep seeing these weird, slimy creatures
everywhere.
They make me kinda sick to look at them, but
I try my best to just keep moving.
I’m on a mission tonight: I’m gonna go
to the local supermarket and check if there’s
still food there, while also grabbing myself
a quick snack.
I’m gonna keep this one brief.
I don’t wanna do a full shopping spree tonight,
it’s already too late.
I just need to know the food is there.
I decided earlier in the night, if I survive
this thing, and the getting is good at the
Bargain Mart, I’ll make my way back tomorrow
for something a little more substantial.
After all, the fewer trips I make out, the
safer I’m likely to be.
By the time I made it to the supermarket,
though, while I was practically a nervous
wreck from the fear of turning into one of
those things, I made an amazing discovery:
While the windows were broken and the floor
was a mess, most of the food was still there.
Day 7.
Or should I say, night seven.
Galvanized by my success from the previous
days, I decided to come back to the supermarket
with a shopping cart.
I wanted to get enough food for at least a
week, so I wouldn’t need to come back out
again.
Hey, maybe I’m not so bad at this whole
apocalypse thing after all…
I grabbed plenty of canned food from the supermarket.
Most of the perishables had already gone moldy
by the time I showed up, so fresh fruit was
out of the question.
Suddenly, I started getting scared about the
thought of scurvy, but pushed it quickly from
my mind.
I’d cross that bridge when I got to it.
Hey hey, it’s Day 8, and I’m still kicking!
That’s gotta count for something, right?
I started taking more trips out at night time,
just to stretch my legs and keep the blood
flowing.
When the slithering things that were once
people passed me, I’d just make myself scarce
and hide in the shadows.
I hear them muttering sometimes in their melted
voices.
It’s unsettling, but it’s amazing what
you’ll get used to in just over a week.
It’s eerie to see all these streets without
people in them.
I know that I should probably just stay inside,
but I can’t.
I don’t know if this will ever just stop,
and if it doesn’t, I don’t want to spend
my last days cooped up in my own basement.
Day 9.
You know, there are some benefits to being
in the post-apocalypse, to ever so slightly
offset all the utterly crushing downsides.
While, during the day, we’re all prisoners
of the sun in our own homes, at night, we
can do whatever the hell we want.
I took a baseball bat I keep in my closet
and went to a local furniture store.
I smashed up every single vase and all the
windows, like one of those Rage Rooms, because
nobody could stop me.
Then, afterwards, I went straight to the local
computer and gaming store and took all the
AlienWare tech I could physically carry.
There’s no value in money anymore.
If you want something, you can just go and
take it.
Every cloud has a silver lining.
Day 10.
More GTA V today.
I decided to get on my headset and speak to
the few others who were still around and on
the servers.
It was so nice to speak to other human beings
for once - They came from all over the world,
and they were dealing with this same “evil
sun” insanity as me.
You have no idea how incredibly valuable it
is to find people to talk to in a time like
this.
The others players had plenty of theories
as to why all this had happened.
Some thought it was some kind of mutant solar
flare they’d remembered reading about on
some conspiracy forum back in the day.
Others speculated that it was the result of
some weapon created by the US or Russian or
Chinese military that’d gone wrong.
One person said that maybe it was a punishment
from God, like maybe, on some level, we all
deserved it.
Things got pretty quiet after that.
Day 11.
I’ve been having the most terrible nightmares
lately.
It’s probably just the product of all the
stress I’ve been under lately.
But, in the nightmares, I’m running down
a dark street, being chased by those flesh
creatures.
I’m moving fast but they’re moving faster.
They’re whispering to me but I can’t make
out anything they’re saying.
This morning - which is to say, this evening
- I woke up screaming and drenched in sweat.
I can’t really explain why, but I feel like
something terrible is going to happen soon…
Okay, okay, I’m alive.
That’s enough, isn’t it?
And if you’re watching this, I assume you’re
alive too.
Congratulations, Welcome to the nightmare
space between day 11 and day 27.
Sorry that I haven’t been in contact for
so long.
As you can see, I’m not at home anymore.
You couldn’t pay me to go back there - Ha.
Not that money is worth anything anymore.
A lot’s happened since I last made one of
these, and I wish I could tell you any of
it was good.
Hell, I wish I could forget it all, but the
things I’ve seen and heard…
I don’t think they’re ever gonna leave
my head, no matter what I do.
I thought about making another entry now and
then, but I always found a reason to put it
off.
It’s remarkable how all your other priorities
fall away when you’re thinking about where
your next meal is coming from, it just kind
of puts everything in perspective.
Of course, during my travels, I saw more of
those freaks slithering around.
Sorry, sorry, I know I shouldn’t call them
that.
It’s kind of a coping mechanism, you know?
It all gets a lot harder when you have to
think of them as…
Ex-people.
That’s another thing all those goofy zombie
shows got wrong: It’s a lot harder to separate
what they were from what they are now, especially
when you know these were your friends, your
neighbors, your…
Well, I can’t avoid talking about it forever,
can I?
I stuffed my backpack with whatever I could
grab and left my home two nights ago.
It wasn’t just because I was going stir
crazy back there, though I admit, that didn’t
exactly help.
It was what happened there.
I’d just come back from a food run, put
most of it in the fridge, then retired back
down into the basement to enjoy a late-night
snack and do a little gaming to keep myself
sane.
I’d been doing everything I could to reverse
my circadian rhythms and sleep during the
day, just so I could be fully operational
during the twelve-hour period that going outside
wouldn’t melt me.
But just like all those stories they told
us when we were kids: There are monsters out
there at night, and they’re looking for
us.
When I first heard the sound, I wondered if
it was something in-game, or maybe dripping
from a leaky pipe.
But no, it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be water.
That’s when I looked at the door and saw
this awful pink slime slithering in underneath
my door.
It was one of those things, those Ex-People,
trying to get in.
That’d be bad enough, but then, it started
talking to me…
“Kyle…
My darling…
Why are you all cooped up down here?
It isn’t healthy.
You ought to come out side, sweetie, get some
sun…”
It was my mom.
Well, it used to be.
Guess she wanted to come over and visit me.
Needless to say, I got out of there, and I’ve
got no intention of going back.
That place is dead to me now.
I don’t ever want to think about that voice
ever again, both her and so…
Not her.
So now, I’m on the move, guess I’ll speak
to you again when I stop.
Stay safe out there.
Day 28.
I decided it was best to make my way out of
town, towards the fringes.
When day first broke, the people who were
in the most densely populated areas were the
first to go.
That’s why I decided to hole up in a gas
station last night, just to avoid the sun.
But during the night, people came.
Not Ex-People, actual people.
They showed up in a Jeep outside the building,
refueled, and then came in.
They were wearing black, cobbled-together
outfits and hockey masks.
They were all either carrying bats or axes,
too.
You can probably understand why I didn’t
decide to introduce myself when they busted
their way in.
I concealed myself in a broom closet while
they searched around.
It was nerve-shredding.
I’d never been more thankful in my life
than when they left.
Day 29.
Coming up on a month of this madness.
After the incident at the gas station, I realized
I needed some kind of defense.
It’s not just the sun and those creatures
I need to worry about.
Just like the old world, people could be dangerous
here too.
That’s why I snuck into a gun store in the
dead of night.
Some of it had been looted, but much like
the supermarket near my home, there was plenty
still here.
The walls were covered in all manner of rifles,
shotguns, and even submachine guns.
I’d heard somewhere that revolvers are more
reliable and easy to maintain than other types,
so since I’m a gun novice, I grabbed a revolver
and stuffed my pockets with as many bullets
as I could carry.
Let’s hope I never need to use any of them.
Day 30.
Do I get to call this a month of survival?
If we’re talking February, I’d be a month
in already.
What a horribly dubious honor that is.
I saw something disgusting last night and
I thought I’d share it just to get it off
my mind.
Last night, as I was moving through the wilderness,
I saw a group of other survivors gathered
around the campfire.
I remained scarce but approached, just to
see what was going on, still carrying my revolver,
just to be safe.
But the people around the campfire were eating
something, and when I saw what they were eating,
I almost threw up.
They were chopping up one of the Ex-People,
cooking the parts over the fire, and eating
it.
Day 31, a month by anyone’s definition.
Ever since seeing those others eating one
of the Ex-people, I’ve had trouble eating
even normal food myself.
My stomach aches and my throat burns.
I feel so weak.
I keep laying down and resting.
I know I need to eat soon if I want to survive
to day 32, but every time I think about eating,
I think about the gooey flesh of the Ex-People.
Sometimes, I wish I hadn’t survived this
long.
I’ll eat soon.
I just need to sleep first…
Day 32 to 43.
If you’ve lived this long, you really ought
to be proud of yourself.
I’ve seen thousands of those slimy Ex-People,
and there are probably millions more out there
- Hell, maybe even billions, if we’re being
honest with ourselves here.
Am I just talking into the void here?
Is there even anyone else out there who’s
human enough to watch this stuff?
Maybe I just need to keep thinking about posterity.
On the off-chance that the world ever gets
better, and we reach some time when children
are born again and all this fades from human
memory, you’ll still have these stupid,
pointless little videos to remember how awful
all this was.
That way, at least I can make myself believe
this all had some kind of point.
So, what’s happened?
With me, not much.
Still moving at night, surviving, hiding in
closets and underground parking complexes
during daylight.
I’m down to my last few cans, so I’m hoping
to hit a supermarket soon.
What a ridiculous way to go: Starving in this
new world, with so many new, interesting ways
to die.
With the Ex-People, things have been a little
more eventful.
There used to be one blob to a person, but
they’ve started…
Joining up?
That’s the best way I can put it.
Things that used to be people and animals
are starting to melt together, getting bigger
and bigger.
They’ve never been aggressive, but I think
it’s best to stay out of their way.
Whatever all this is about, I’m streetwise
enough now to know it can’t be anything
good.
I’ll just keep moving, and I hope you can
do the same, whoever the hell you are.
Hopefully, the next time I check in with you,
it’s with better news than this.
Day 44.
I saw a shootout on the road last night.
The people who are left, the ones who are
still indeed people, are becoming less human.
Something about situations like this, this
sustained stress and pain and hopelessness,
it weighs on you.
There are no rules in the post-apocalypse,
the only thing that can stop you from doing
anything is a bullet to the head.
Five or six people last night, as afraid and
desperate and hungry as me, gunned each other
down.
They did this for reasons I will never understand,
even if I wanted to, because there are no
survivors left to tell the tale.
What a funny world we live in.
Day 45.
I sleep when I can.
It’s surreal, I remember when I feared the
dark and loved bright, sunny days.
Even all this time in, I still don’t think
I’m used to the switch being flipped.
I’ve been having awful dreams again.
I’m still running in them, with a deep red
sun shining up in the sky.
I’m being chased by a mountain of flesh
the size of Mount Everest.
It’s swallowing up the city behind me.
It keeps getting closer.
No matter how fast I go, I just can’t escape.
It’ll get me eventually.
Something terrible is going to happen soon.
I just know it.
Day 46.
I shot a man today.
I don’t know if he survived; I hope he lived.
We encountered each other inside an abandoned
building.
I think we spooked each other and didn’t
have any time to ask if we were friends or
foes.
We were too afraid either way.
We both drew our weapons, and I was faster
than he was.
When my revolver discharged and he collapsed,
I ran off.
Sun would come up in a few hours, and I just
needed to find another place to hide.
What the hell have I become?
I don’t know how things could get any worse
than this.
Note to self, in the future, don’t even
dare to think “How could things get any
worse?”
Because if I’ve learned anything since this
whole nightmare started, that is never a rhetorical
question.
Welcome to the space between Day 47 and Day
64.
If you’re still alive and watching this,
I’m so sorry.
So, I’ve got good news and bad news.
I’ll give you the good news first: I’ve
seen more people who haven’t been changed
yet.
And the bad news?
Last time I saw them, they were being dragged
out into the light, kicking and screaming,
in the tendrils of one of those horrible flesh
monsters I was telling you about last time.
They’ve gotten a lot bigger now, and when
I told you they weren’t aggressive, well,
I spoke a little too soon.
I can’t just sleep during the day like I
used to.
These monsters - and that’s what they are
now, they’re monsters, not people anymore
- they patrol, they hunt.
They actively enter buildings, searching for
hiding places, searching for people they can
drag out into the light.
I’ve seen it with my own two eyes - The
second they’re out, they just start melting
and fusing with the mass, making it even bigger,
adding another voice to the chorus.
And I hate myself, cause every time I’ve
seen it happen, all I can think is, “Thank
god that’s not me.”
I wish I could do something to help, to save
them, but that’s not the world we live in.
The second they touch the light, it’s already
over.
I wouldn’t be helping anyone by adding my
flesh to one of those things.
I don’t want them using my body to get other
people.
There’s only one thing I can do now: Keep
moving at night, stay hidden, get away from
population centers.
I’ve realized where I need to go now: I’ve
still got a distant memory of those broadcasts
in the early days of the event.
The SCP Foundation.
I noted down coordinates to the nearest facility
they had on the books - And if I’m honest,
“nearest” is only a relative term, cause
at this rate, it’s gonna take me an eternity
to get there.
But it’ll be worth it in the end, when I
get there.
It’ll all be worth it if I can at least
get some answers, at least know why the world
turned into this Hell.
Those SCP folks seemed better prepared for
this than anyone, so even if they can’t
fix this, they’ve at least got to have answers,
right?
Somebody needs to have answers.
I really want to believe that.
When the sun goes down, I’ll start moving
again.
If you’re watching this, wish me luck.
I don’t have much food left.
I’ll do what I can.
Yeah, I realize I’m not looking great right
now, but trust me, you should see the other
guy.
Day 65 to Day 86.
Never thought I’d make it this far, but
life’s just full of surprises.
Before you ask - and I mean, why would you
ask?
It’s not like I can hear you - it wasn’t
one of the monsters that did this to me, it
was another person, just like me.
Desperate, hungry, afraid.
The one difference between me and them was
the fact they had a handgun, and I didn’t.
They asked for all the food I had, and when
I wasn’t exactly forthcoming, they decided
to shoot me, and steal the last of my food
while I lay bleeding on the ground.
Well, that’s not entirely fair.
They did leave me with one protein bar, which
I had to cave and eat a couple of days ago.
Since then, I’ve just been foraging what
little food I can from plants along the way
during my nighttime walks.
But it isn’t much, and my wound is giving
me grief.
I sure hope they’ve got doctors at this
SCP Foundation, or otherwise, I may be even
more out of luck than I thought.
Here’s the good news for you, since I know
how much you love that.
I’m not far off of the Foundation site now.
Even in this state, I’m probably only a
couple of weeks away.
I think maybe I can will myself to live that
long, at least.
If I can get some answers just before I die,
then I can die happy.
And sometimes, folks, that’s all you can
ask for.
Final stretch.
Let’s hope I see you again on the other
end.
Stay safe…
But…
I don’t understand.
Where is everybody?
Hello?
Is anybody there?
God damn it, why is nobody here?
I don’t understand.
They were meant to have the answers.
They were meant to know what was going on
here, but they’re all gone too.
It isn’t fair, it isn’t fair.
Is this it?
Is it all just over?
The end of the freaking world as we know it?
It isn’t fair, it isn’t fair, it isn’t
fair…
Wait…
Are those footsteps?
Hello? Yes, hello, I’m over here!
Who’s there?
Oh my god, what the hell is that thing!?
No, no, get away from me, oh god!
“Disgusting…”
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
I’m trapped in the Infinite Ikea!
How long have I been here?
How can I get out?
How can I survive the vicious Staff of the
Infinite Ikea and work with the other survivors
in this terrifying, endless building?
Okay.
Let’s start from the beginning.
Day 1.
I’d come to this flat-pack nightmare with
my lovely wife, Brenda, to pick up some stupid
sofa she saw online.
We could have ordered it in, but me, being
a cheapskate and a fool, instead decided it’d
be a dandy idea to head in and pick it up
ourselves - even though I can’t stand shopping
in these giant stores.
Of course, it didn’t take long for us to
get separated.
I was wandering around, just pretending I
knew what I was doing.
Surrounded by unfamiliar people.
Then…
Not surrounded by any people at all.
Like the complete doofus I was, I’d somehow
gotten lost.
Just needed to find my bearings again and
then I could call Brenda to come save me.
But I never did find my bearings.
The hours went on, and I was still lost…
Day 2.
My dominant emotion on this day was nothing
more than sheer humiliation, knowing I’d
been bested by a damn Swedish furniture store.
I spent the night before sleeping on a futon,
wondering how I’d gotten myself into this
flat-pack calamity.
I spent the day searching for food, my confusion
and exhaustion increasing by the moment.
For a while, I even entertained the idea I
might have died and gone to some Nordic hell.
That night, I went to bed hungry, knowing
that if I didn’t eat soon, I might be found
as a skeleton on a dusty old futon.
It can’t end like this.
I can’t die on day 2…
Day 3.
I continued my journey through the labyrinthine
bowels of the Ikea, disoriented by the endlessly
iterating collections of cheap furniture.
There was something terrifying about the emptiness
of it all, this affordable but impossible
to assemble void.
Starvation has always been one of the most
horrific deaths, hasn’t it?
You could only imagine my relief when I saw
the figure standing a few feet in front of
me, dressed like a member of Ikea staff.
I’d found salvation!
I’d found someone who could help me out
of here!
But when I approached, I realized something
was horribly wrong: This wasn’t a human
being standing before me, it was a monster.
A being I’d later come to know is called
The Staff by the many people who fear them.
It chased me, repeating, “The store is closed.
You need to vacate the premises”, flailing
for me with its long, frightening limbs.
I only survived Day 3 because I locked myself
in a closet and just waited while it hammered
against the wood with its fists.
Once the “night” was over, it left, and
I was able to escape.
Day 4.
I was feeling some intense hunger pangs on
this day, not to mention the fact that I now
knew there were monsters out there, just waiting
to beat me to death if they caught me when
the lights turned down.
Needless to say, I wasn’t in the best headspace,
and I didn’t have enough charge on my phone
to justify opening up my meditation app.
Then…
I found Nirvana.
I found the cafeteria, stocked full of delicious,
warm Swedish meatballs.
No food had ever tasted so sweet to me.
And this delicious meal also gave way to one
of the most exciting new developments: Gloria.
Gloria was a veteran.
She taught me everything I needed to know
at this place.
Even on the first day I met her, she felt
like someone I’d known for years.
It was her that took me back to her home in
this place: A little fortress made of Ikea
furniture, filled with a whole community of
other people trapped in there.
It was like being allowed into the Garden
of Eden.
Day 5, and it feels good to be alive.
I met up with all the different people around
the camp.
They tell the most bizarre and fascinating
stories.
This sounds crazy, I know, but I get the sense
not all of them came from the same place as
me.
Different Ikeas in different countries, or
maybe even - as nutty as it sounds - from
different worlds.
One guy, Tony, who’s been trapped in here
for a year and change, and we got talking
about different vacations we’d taken on
the outside.
He told me he was from New York, and I told
him I visited there once, and I loved going
to see the Statue of Liberty up close.
That’s when he told me that he’d never
heard of the Statue of Liberty.
I didn’t know what to make of that.
Strange little details aside, I couldn’t
be happier to be there with other people.
The next step would be finding a way out of
here, and back to Brenda.
Day 6.
Gloria and several others led me out on our
first excursion - Missions where the goal
was to collect more food and supplies, and
map the surrounding area.
I nearly jumped out of my skin when I saw
a Staff member standing in our path at one
point, and the others all just laughed at
me.
The Staff member just stood there, placid
and still.
Gloria told me that it’s okay, the Staff
are harmless during the day.
It’s only nighttime when they enter their
pattern of aggression.
So as long as you don’t get lost during
the daytime, you’re generally fine.
The team often used string, like Theseus,
to trail behind them and ensure they don’t
get lost.
It was clear they’d been here long enough
to work out systems for every possibility.
Felt like I was in good hands with them.
We collected meatballs and some rugs to fortify
the walls and headed back.
Day 7.
This was the first night that we had to fend
off a full-on attack.
Those monsters, the Staff, came at us in huge
groups, pounding at the outside of our perimeter
with their balled fists.
It was terrifying.
As a way of fighting them off, we tied Ikea
kitchen knives to the end of curtain rails
and speared them, one by one, until all of
them were dead.
But they just kept coming.
More and more and more of them.
When it looked like one of the walls to the
north of the community was going to fall,
everyone around me started to panic.
That’s when Barry, one of the biggest men
in the camp, grabbed a hammer in each hand
and when outside.
He fought like a beast, taking on Staff member
after Staff member, tanking hit after hit.
It was something to see.
That’s when he took off into the depths
of the store, drawing the Staff away behind
him and saving us all.
We never saw Barry again after that, but he’s
the reason all of us made it past day 7.
Thank you, Barry, wherever you are.
Day 8.
Gloria took me out alone today, on another
search for the escape.
That’s when she told me about her sister:
She’d gone shopping in Ikea with her well
over a year ago now, when she was separated
and got lost in here, just like me.
I had a lot in common with her, including
my feelings of guilt for abandoning my loved
ones and my drive to escape and be united
with them.
While we were out that day, we didn’t find
anything useful.
Gloria seemed sad but unsurprised.
The Infinite Ikea had its way of slowly grinding
you down.
Days 9 to 17.
Despite a rocky start, I was finding my legs
in the Infinite Ikea.
I started to get to know my fellow Ikea prisoners,
I started to understand and truly befriend
them.
We went on expeditions pretty much daily,
either to collect new food, more supplies
to help build up our community, or to keep
searching for an exit.
To me, it started to feel like we were making
progress, and that helped a great deal to
keep my emotions semi-stable.
But it wasn’t the same for Gloria.
After all, she’d been here for so much longer
than me, and she had her sister to consider
on the outside.
To her, these routines I was becoming part
of now felt like a prison within the prison.
She was trapped.
Had her sister forgotten her out there?
Had she been declared dead?
Were people even still looking for her?
And it was on Day 18 that it all got a little
too much for poor Gloria.
She’d snuck out of the camp at night, when
the staff were most active, trying to find
the exit.
Sadly, that’d cost Gloria her life.
There’s no way of knowing what happened
to her exactly, but considering how bruised
up her body was when we found her, it was
easy to make an educated guess: She’d gotten
bum-rushed by the Staff and beaten to death
before she could even muster up a defense.
It was a horrible day to go.
We tried to give her as dignified a funeral
as we could, given the circumstances: Closing
her up in a body-sized box.
That was the day I decided to stop just trying
to survive, and start trying to escape.
I owed that to Brenda, if she really had gotten
out.
I couldn’t keep her waiting.
But I wouldn’t be alone.
As it turns out, another two members of the
little Ikea community I’d come to know were
willing to risk it all with me: A man named
Kelvin and a young woman named Vicky.
They were sick of just waiting around and
fending off attacks from the Staff, night
after night.
They both told me they’d rather die during
an escape attempt than while cowering under
a pile of cheap rugs.
And so, each armed with claw hammers from
the Six-Piece Ikea Fixa tool kit and as many
Pruta Tupperware containers full of meatballs
as we could carry, we set off into the great
unknown… of Ikea.
We traveled for weeks, marking out tracks
on the ground with the MÅLA mixed-colors
chalk selection so we never got caught going
in circles.
One day bled into the next: Nights were spent
trying to hide in closets and bathtub while
the Staff hunted relentlessly for people just
like us.
Every single time, we got lucky.
Until day 41.
Here’s something you need to know about
the Infinite Ikea: You’re probably already
aware, if you’re watching this, that the
24-hour cycle of night and day is dictated
by the store lights up above.
But the space between day and night isn’t
a gradient here, it’s a cliff.
You can be minding your own business, when
suddenly, pitch darkness, and now the staff
are on your ass.
That’s exactly what happened on Day 41.
We were in the middle of a kitchenware section,
surrounded by a few docile members of staff,
when suddenly, the lights switched off and
they went hostile on us.
They look pretty goofy after the initial shock
has worn off, but believe me when I say that
these monsters can really pack a mean wallop
when they want to, and we received a reminder
of this unfortunate fact that night.
The staff swarmed us, repeating that awful
phrase, “The store is closed.
You need to vacate the premises”, while
they struck and flailed at us.
If it wasn’t for our trusty claw hammers,
we would have been dead that night.
Thankfully, we were able to give better than
we were getting.
We managed to kill a decent number of staff
members and then make a run for a section
with better hiding places.
Myself, Vicky, and Kelvin all stowed away
in a large wardrobe until we saw light filtering
through the crack in the door, like we were
rejected extras for some painful community
theatre take on The Chronicles of Narnia.
But while we survived that night, we didn’t
survive unscathed.
My face was swollen from a nasty punch one
of the staff members dealt me, and from the
pain in my chest, I might’ve been dealing
with a few broken ribs.
Kelvin sprained his ankle during the escape,
and Vicky had a cut on her forehead from when
one of the staff members kneed her in the
face during the fray.
You never win these fights, you just survive
them.
We made a temporary camp in the area where
we could rest and recover, as well as shaking
off the justifiable fear of death or grievous
harm that dampened our resolve to get out
of this place.
That took us to day 53.
Of course, food was always a concern.
I don’t want to romanticize what happened
in there, as much as I’m sure someone on
the outside might want to imagine this whole
experience as some kind of exciting, survival
horror game.
But I assure you, it was less “survival
horror” and more survival and horror.
Meaning not only are we suffering from constant
fear, stress, and paranoia for our safety
in here, but we also need to keep ourselves
fed and watered.
You’re just as likely to die from starvation
in here as you are to be beaten to death.
We went in search of another Ikea Kitchen,
where we could fill up on more water and meatballs
- your lifeblood in a place like this.
It took us several more days of searching
and hiding, searching and hiding before we
hit paydirt.
By the time we actually got our hands on the
food and water, we were starving and practically
coughing up dust.
Those meatballs were the most delicious food
I’ve ever tasted, and I could tell from
their faces that Kelvin and Vicky felt exactly
the same way.
Though at that moment, I told myself, if - no,
when - I get out of here, I’d never eat
another meatball.
It’d probably give me war flashbacks - or,
I guess, store flashbacks.
We filled up our Tupperware and shoved them
back into our Ikea Pivring backpacks.
Then, we needed to keep moving, keep searching,
and keep marking the ground behind us as we
fanned out into the great flat-pack yonder,
avoiding confrontations whenever we could.
The three of us still had no idea what insanity
was waiting for us out there.
We had no idea that there were even more dangerous
things than the Staff lurking in the shadows.
Day 68.
Of course, I kept count, writing it down in
my on the back of a JÄTTELIK coloring book.
Trust me, when every night could mean a horrible
death, you keep track of the nights.
Not a single one of them escapes you.
At a certain point, I think we all adapted,
in our own way.
It was back to caveman times again, learning
to be like our primal ancestors, hiding away
from the dark and the monsters that hid there.
So it was extremely surprising for us to get
the most brutal attack during the day.
At first, I thought we were being attacked
by the staff during daylight hours, like a
bolt from the blue.
That’s when we noticed they weren’t attacking
with their hands: They were all holding kitchen
knives, holding us up like bandits.
That’s when we realized what had actually
happened here: We weren’t being attacked
by the staff, we were being attacked by other
humans dressed like the staff, wearing their
hollowed-out heads like grisly masks.
They told us that we were coming with them,
and if we resisted, they’d cut us to ribbons.
And seeing as none of us were movie action
heroes, we thought it’d be best to do exactly
what they said.
This was how we fell into the clutches of
Generalissimo Vardagen.
Day 69, but things were not nice.
I don’t know if I mentioned this before,
but the community I became a part of in the
Infinite Ikea after meeting Gloria was just
one of many.
Nobody knows exactly how many people are trapped
in here.
I’m hardly a martyr for spending 68 days
in there, I know people who’ve been trapped
in there for years, who’ve given up all
hope of escape and accepted their lot in life.
They became the elders of a lot of these communities,
helping others adjust.
Though of course, Generalissimo Vardagen was
not one of these people.
Myself, Vicky, and Kelvin were dragged by
the strangers dressed as staff members into
a fort made of smashed-up wood, nailed together
into a huge, ominous structure.
It was a far more extensive structure than
any of the communities I’d visited or even
heard about before in the Infinite Ikea.
It was a true fortress, guarded by many more
of those knife-wielding people, dressed in
the clothes and the flesh of the staff.
They looked like some evil cult straight out
of a damn horror movie; I’d never seen anything
like it.
We were dragged into a kind of tent in the
middle of the camp, made out of stitched-together
rugs.
That’s where we met Generlissimo Vardagen,
surrounded by his guards.
I’d later learn his namesake was a set of
steak knives stocked in the Ikea kitchenware
sections - similar to the knives being wielded
by his gallery of goons.
The Generalissimo himself was dressed like
some absurd tinpot dictator, wearing a silly
hat and a jacket covered in fake medals.
His whole presence felt like a cosmic punishment
for daring to believe things couldn’t get
any more absurd than they already were.
His men forced us down onto our knees, and
Vardagen cleared his throat to speak.
“Quake in fear at the sight of this Ikea’s
ruler, the great and powerful Generalissimo
Vardagen.
I have united kingdoms from the gardening
and bathroom supplies departments, and crushed
dissenting tribes in the office furniture
section to the West.
If you wish to live, you will swear fealty
to me and join my legion of servants.
If you do as I say, you will be given safety
and security from the staff come nightfall.
If you do not bend the knee, I will have you
destroyed!”
By the time his little spiel was done, the
man was red in the face and sweating profusely.
It was clear that, much like your average
Ikea shelving unit after a couple weeks of
use, the great Generalissimo Vardagen had
a few screws loose.
None of us liked the idea of becoming slaves
to some flat-pack ghenghis khan, so we tried
to persuade him to just let us go, telling
him that we hoped to escape the store, and
with our help, he could escape, too.
That’s when we learned a sobering lesson:
For some people, life inside the Infinite
Ikea was better than life outside.
In the real world, the Generalissimo had been
a twice-divorced ex-salaryman with nothing
to his name but debts and regrets.
But here, he was a demi-god.
A leader among the rest of us mere mortals.
Why would he ever want to go back to the world
that had given him nothing and taken everything?
Day 70 to Day 84.
We were forced into weeks of hard labor after
that, toiling under the Generalissimo and
his gang of brigands.
The soldiers worked us like dogs, making us
carry food and furniture back to the Generalissimo’s
Scandanavian furniture fortress.
One day bled into the next.
The best I could say about any of this was
that at least we were safe behind the walls
of the fortress at night, so we didn’t need
to worry about getting murdered by the staff
in our sleep.
However, tragedy struck again on day 85.
Kelvin couldn’t take the work anymore.
One day, I think his mind just snapped.
He refused to follow orders from the Generalissimo
and his lieutenants, even when they threatened
him with death.
Sadly, that night they would prove that this
wasn’t just some empty threat.
When night fell, they tied up Kelvin’s arms
and legs and left him outside the fortress.
We were just forced to watch as the staff
assembled and beat our friend to death while
he lay there, unable to defend himself.
Even in all the time I’d spent in the Infinite
Ikea, that was the most harrowing thing I’d
ever seen.
But in one of the few acts of righteous cosmic
justice that we’d seen since being trapped
in here, all those months ago, just a few
days after Kelvin’s brutal execution.
Day 90.
The day of the revolution.
While I’d love to tell you I started this,
there are no heroes in this story, I just
happen to be the one telling you about it.
Some internal conflict between the Generalissimo
and his men boiled over into a kind of civil
war that tore the fortress apart from within.
Vicky and I escaped, but in different directions.
I like to imagine she got out in the end,
it helps me sleep at night.
But one thing I will tell you: Generalissimo
Vardagen found out what happened to tyrants,
big and small, when his closest confidantes
gave him the Julias Caesar treatment with
the knives from which he took his name.
I don’t think there’s anything wrong in
taking a little joy in that.
For days afterwards, I just walked.
I felt so empty, but I refused to just lay
down and let myself die.
Even though so much of the hope had been beaten
out of me, I couldn’t betray Brenda by just
giving up in here.
It wouldn’t be right.
It just wouldn’t be right.
The days ticked on, and nothing changed.
I had no food, no weapons.
I was getting so tired.
Then… night fell, and the Staff started
chasing me.
They seemed even more aggressive than before.
I couldn’t fight; all I could do was run.
I ran and I ran and I ran, not even looking
where I was going, as the crowd of staff started
catching up with me.
Getting closer and closer.
I ran until there was a doorway before me.
I didn’t even think, I was just trying to
get away.
That’s when I noticed that the store’s
roof was no longer above me.
For the first time in one hundred days, I
was once again tasting fresh air.
That’s right, folks.
On day one hundred, I was out.
I’d truly made it out.
This victory, however, was short-lived: A
group of about six staff members burst out
of the front door behind me, charging towards
me with ferocious speed.
I couldn’t move, all I could do was grit
my teeth and wince, ready to accept my death
at what had otherwise been the high point
of my recent life.
What a depressing irony that would be.
But instead, gunshots rang out through the
air.
A hail of bullets cleaved through the staff
members, dropping them to the ground mere
feet away from me, stone dead.
That’s when I turned to see a group of men
with assault rifles and tactical gear walking
towards me.
In any other situation, this might have been
terrifying, but right then, it was the happiest
moment of my life.
These men took me away from the parking lot
of what was now an abandoned Ikea.
They told me they were from a group called
the SCP Foundation, and that I’d been declared
missing for some time now.
I didn’t care about any of that: I just
asked them if Brenda had gotten out.
If she hadn’t escaped too, then this was
all for nothing.
You can’t even imagine my relief when they
told me that Brenda was never even trapped.
She was the one who reported my disappearance
after I’d dropped off the face of the earth
in what she thought was a perfectly normal
Ikea shopping session, before that building
was shut down and cordoned off under some
less-insane pretense.
But Brenda was alive and safe, and I’d get
to be with her again.
I have no shame in telling you I cried, but
I’d like to specify that they were absolutely
tears of joy.
The men from the SCP Foundation told me that
they’d give me medicine that’d help me
forget all this after I told them my story,
and there’s no part of me that has a problem
with that.
Some things are better left forgotten.
But before the SCP Foundation wipes it all
from my mind and I get to go and live with
my beloved wife once more, this was how I
survived 100 dreadful days in the Infinite
Ikea.
Glass shatters, a D-Class screams, the shrill
cry of the alarm sounds.
There's been a containment breach at the SCP
Foundation!
Somehow, The Plague Doctor has escaped his
cell, and is making a break for it!
Against all odds, he finds the exit, and he's
out!
He's free, he's on the lam!
But how long can he elude the Foundation's
attempts to track him down, and recontain
him at any cost?
It will take all of his cunning, his intellect,
and his strange anomalous abilities, but he's
going to try and hold onto his newfound freedom
as tightly as he can.
I'm getting ahead of myself here, though.
Let's start at the beginning.
Day 1.
SCP-049, or The Plague Doctor, may be an esoteric
anomaly whose grasp of medicine is practically
Medieval, but he's still a doctor!
He didn't get this far by not paying attention
to his surroundings.
So, when an unexpected power outage, triggered
by an experiment gone wrong somewhere in the
bowels of Site-19, gave him the chance to
escape captivity?
He took it.
The Foundation had recently revoked his access
to live experimental subjects again, and he
had had enough.
It was time to seize the moment and make a
mad dash for freedom.
With the security system down, the Doctor
broke open the door to his cell, grabbed his
trusty apothecary bag, and ran into the hall.
Guards were already swarming, ready to drag
him back into captivity, but he had planned
ahead.
Swiftly, he uncorked a glass bottle of silvery
liquid, spilling it onto the floor, where
it began to eat away at the tile, the shoes
of the guards, and, if they maintained contact
for too long, the soles of their feet.
This bought him just enough time to keep running.
The sounds of screaming down another hall,
and the raucous laughter of one Dr. Jack Bright,
signaled to the Doctor that most of the Foundation
staff were otherwise occupied.
With this in mind, he sprinted on, letting
his chitinous body carry him to the exit.
Then, for the first time in far too long,
fresh air on his beak, the sun in his eyes,
the scent of cut grass and damp leaves from
last night's rain.
The world was here, waiting for him just as
he had left it.
Of course, the world was still very much in
danger.
He hadn't just broken free for himself, but
to address the Pestilence head on as best
he could.
But for now, as he heard the sound of the
alarm, the guards gaining on him, he had to
prioritize his own safety first.
He had to hide.
Day 2.
He ran for ages, he couldn't be quite sure
how long as he had no way to measure the passage
of time except the position of the sun in
the sky.
It set, it rose, bathing the countryside in
soft yellow light, and set again, plunging
the land into darkness, all while he continued
to run.
Then, finally, the Plague Doctor stopped.
He had found a farm.
There was a little farmhouse, but he did not
dare disturb the sleeping family and alarm
them.
Instead, he turned to the barn for shelter.
He let himself in, tiptoed past the horses
as they slept there, and made himself a bed
from straw and a burlap sack.
From his bag, he pulled a pillow, and a little
spray bottle.
He misted the pillow with a lavender scented
oil, and finally allowed himself a moment
to rest.
He did not need to sleep like ordinary men,
but after such a long journey, he could get
pretty close.
Day 3.
The morning of the Plague Doctor's third day
of freedom began with the high-pitched whinny
of a terrified horse, and the frantic stamping
of hooves.
The Doctor opened his eyes to the sight of
one of the horses, now awake and not at all
happy to see a stranger in its barn, making
its fear and displeasure known.
"Buttercup?"
A man called from outside the barn.
"That you, girl?
What's got you spooked?"
The door to the barn creaked open, and before
the Doctor could do anything, he was face
to face with the farmer who owned the land.
"Who are you and what are you doing in my
barn?"
The man demanded.
"Good sir, I apologize for the intrusion!
I am but a humble traveler, seeking shelter-"
"You need to get out of here and stop scaring
my horses, now!
Don't make me come back with my shotgun."
"No need for that sort of thing!
I will be on my way!"
The Doctor collected his things, and, deciding
to spare the old farmer rather than using
more extreme methods to change his mind, left
the barn in a hurry.
Day 4.
With the farm far behind him, the Plague Doctor
trudged along on his journey, always keeping
an eye out for unmarked vans and armed guards.
So far, though, he was safe.
He hadn't had a spare moment to return to
his experiments, though, which was beginning
to wear on him.
The work was what had motivated him to break
out in the first place, and now he wasn't
sure when he would be able to make time for
it.
Cruel irony indeed.
But then, as if his silent prayer had been
answered, he heard a peculiar sound coming
from the woods just off the dirt road he was
walking down.
A sickly bray, from an injured animal.
A poor soul in need.
A patient!
He followed the sound to its source: a deer
lay on its side, clearly sick or injured somehow.
"Do not be afraid, my friend."
The Doctor said softly.
"You are sick, but I can make you well."
He sat his bag down on the grass, and got
to work.
First, he touched the deer with a gloved hand,
stopping its heart and putting it out of its
misery.
Then, he reached into his bag for his trusty
tools and some of his best medicines.
In no time at all, the deer was reanimated,
cured, walking around again like new.
Sure, it was a little bit different, stumbling
a bit, and each eye looked in a different
direction, but the Doctor considered the treatment
a success.
A day well-spent!
Day 5
The next day, feeling reinvigorated after
his successful encounter with the deer, the
Plague Doctor began his quest for shelter
anew.
He walked most of the day, until, as the sun
was setting, he came upon something curious:
a house, dilapidated-looking, with a large
sign out front: "House of Horrors, Enter if
You Dare."
Though he didn't know it, the Doctor had stumbled
upon the local town's premiere seasonal haunted
house attraction.
To him, it was simply an empty house he could
take up residence inside.
He was curious, and a bit perplexed, as he
walked past plastic skeletons, animatronic
werewolves that popped out from behind styrofoam
tombstones, and giant fake spiders in cotton
cobwebs.
None of the fake monsters gave him trouble,
so, though he was confused by what he saw,
he continued to explore the house.
Then, he found something incredible: a laboratory.
There was a long stainless steel table, with
a mannequin strapped to it.
A row of prop surgical tools sat on a tray
next to the mannequin, and along a back shelf
were rows and rows of jars filled with liquids
that looked like something the Plague Doctor
himself would pull out of his bag.
He couldn't believe his eyes, after wandering
aimlessly for days he had found the perfect
place.
Almost as if it had been made just for him.
Of course, it wasn't, it was for the paying
customers who would be coming to the haunted
house the next day, along with the actors
hired to perform inside, but he didn't need
to know any of that yet.
He replaced the jars with his own, and the
tools with functioning ones.
With the exception of the plastic body on
the table, which he privately wished was a
real human subject, this was absolutely perfect.
Day 6, the haunt actors showed up for work,
and were surprised to find a new guy had beat
them there, and he was already in costume.
They shrugged it off, they were making minimum
wage and that wasn't enough to ask any questions.
They were there to suit up and get spooky,
and that was it.
They did appreciate his plague doctor costume,
though.
It was much higher-budget than anything they
had.
"Did you make that getup yourself?"
Asked a friendly zombie.
"Indeed, I did!"
The Doctor replied cheerfully, happy to finally
encounter a group of individuals who were
unafraid of him.
"Nice, bro!"
The zombie gave him a thumbs-up, and if the
Plague Doctor could have with his rigid beaked
face, he would have smiled.
These new colleagues were a bit unusual-looking,
with their ghostly white faces, vampire fangs,
green-tinged makeup and excess fur, but their
kindness was encouraging.
Meanwhile, the haunt actors were gossiping
amongst themselves, wondering where the new
plague doctor character came from.
Who approved it?
Who hired this guy?
Why was he doing that accent?
Whatever, he was plenty scary and a nice enough
guy to work with, so Frankenstein's Monster
let the Plague Doctor have the laboratory
set, and moved himself into the graveyard.
The customers loved him too, shrieking with
delight as he welcomed them into his laboratory,
asking if any of them would like to volunteer
to be a test subject.
Lucky for them, they had already been warned
not to touch any of the "actors" while walking
through the attraction.
As his first night at his unintentional job
came to a close, the Plague Doctor's new friends
bid him farewell.
"We're going to a bar up the road for a couple
drinks!"
The ghostly bridge said.
"Wanna come?"
"Ah, no time for revelry!"
The Plague Doctor replied.
"I must attend to my work.
Take care!"
The woman just laughed.
"Okay, see you later."
And so the Plague Doctor spent his night in
the haunted house again, tinkering with his
tools and his tissue samples, listening to
the royalty-free scary music tape play again
and again on repeat, into the night.
Day 7.
The next day, attendance at the haunted house
was slow.
The actors, with little to do, spent their
time scrolling aimlessly on their phones,
filming joke videos for social media, and
pranking each other.
One of them got the bright idea to pull a
prank on the new hire, the stranger that none
of them knew much about.
He would have a friend, turn out the lights
in the laboratory, and when the lights were
turned back on, he would have replaced the
mannequin on the table.
He couldn't have known what would happen.
All he wanted to do was startle the new guy,
freak him out with the sight of an unexpected
werewolf on his operating table.
And it was effective- sort of.
The Plague Doctor froze in place when the
lights went out, calling, "Hello?
What is happening?"
and when the room was illuminated once more,
he took in the sight of the living being on
the operating table.
"My friend!
You have come to me for treatment?"
The werewolf started to get up, disappointed
he hadn't managed to elicit a scream, but
the Plague Doctor reached out a hand to stop
him, and that was curtains for that particular
actor.
As soon as the Plague Doctor's gloved hand
made contact with the man in the werewolf
costume, his heart stopped.
"Oh dear."
The Plague Doctor remarked.
"Do not fear, I have the cure.
You'll be alright in no time at all"
By the time the rest of the actors came to
see what had happened to the werewolf, there
was a real zombie in the haunted house.
Then, it was pure chaos.
Actors running and screaming, knocking over
props and abandoning their seasonal gig, darting
between customers as they went, shrieking
"Don't go in there!
It's real!"
Naturally, this only made them want to check
it out even more.
But by the time they got inside, there was
no sign of the Plague Doctor.
Only one very lost zombie in a werewolf costume,
a few jars broken in all the chaos, and footsteps
in the dry grass outside, leading out of town.
Days 8 to 18
The Plague Doctor spent all of his eighth
day on the run walking, once more.
He was starting to get used to this, the endless
drudgery of the path to freedom.
He hated to admit it, but he was almost starting
to miss his cell back at the Foundation, the
routine of it, the quiet time to work, the
three meals given to him each day even though
he didn't need to eat to survive.
He missed food and drink, the simple pleasures
of bread, meat, cheese, fruit.
A mug of tea, a cup of wine.
He sighed to himself, wistfully.
Then, he caught a whiff of something lovely.
He lifted his beak, taking another deep breath.
The unmistakable scent of roast pheasant,
hearty and warm.
Beneath it, something else.
Mulled wine, spiced and inviting.
Smells that reminded him of home, of days
long lost.
He couldn't be certain where it would lead,
or if there would be a seat for him at the
table, but he couldn't resist following the
heavenly aroma to its source.
As he drew closer to the smell of food and
merriment, he could hear music.
The plucking of a lyre, the high trill of
a flute, singing and clapping.
Then, he finally spotted it.
Rows of colorful tents, long banquet tables,
minstrels wandering about and playing ballads
to anyone who would listen.
Men, women, and children frolicking in elaborate
costumes, plate armor, robes, gowns, and more.
Though the Plague Doctor didn't know how to
describe what he was seeing, he had wandered
onto the site of one of the state's largest
Renaissance Faires.
It just so happened to be opening day, and
he was just in time for the celebratory feast.
"Good day, Doctor!"
A nobleman tipped his hat to SCP-049.
"Are you speaking to me?"
The Plague Doctor was taken aback by the recognition.
"Why of course, you're the only doctor I see!
Her Majesty the Queen thanks you for your
service, for keeping us all safe from the
great plague!"
The Plague Doctor had no idea that this man
was an actor, playing along with him in what
he assumed was a scene for the tourists.
Instead, he took the words to heart, swelling
with pride and gratitude for the recognition.
"Good sir, it is my duty and my honor."
The Plague Doctor nodded politely.
Luckily for him, and unbeknownst to the rest
of the cast of players at the Faire, the man
originally hired to play the town Plague Doctor
had booked a commercial role that morning
and had decided not to go in to work.
That man's choice not to call and let anyone
know, though rude, led to a fortuitous misunderstanding
for SCP-049.
"Please, join us at the Royal Table!"
The nobleman made a sweeping gesture with
his arm, inviting the doctor to sit and dine
with him and the rest of the actors playing
members of the court.
"Thank you for your kindness."
If he could, the Plague Doctor would have
smiled.
He dined to his heart's content that afternoon,
listening to sounds of music and laughter.
He slotted into his role at the Faire even
better than his position at the Haunted House.
He answered questions from tourists about
his work as a physician, warned them of the
dangers of the Great Pestilence, and posed
for the occasional photograph.
He spent a wonderful ten days living in a
stylized, artificial version of the past,
basking in the warm glow of camaraderie - though
the other actors wondered why he never took
his mask off, even to eat.
Then, sadly, it was time for the Faire to
pack up for the season.
The Plague Doctor bid his new friends farewell,
and declined their offers to exchange numbers
and keep in touch.
He would, however, always remember them fondly.
Days 19-41
As he was departing the Faire grounds, the
Doctor caught a glimpse of strange men approaching
some of the actors, showing federal badges
and asking them questions.
He couldn't be certain that it was the Foundation,
but it was more than enough to make him cautious.
He would have to retreat into the woods once
more, and stay out of sight.
He laid low for quite some time, for 22 days
to be exact, but then, on Day 41…
Day 41 to 52.
It started to snow.
White blanketed the forest floor, soft and
cold.
The weather wouldn't kill him, of course,
but it was uncomfortable.
He would need to find some more efficient
shelter, to escape from the elements before
the winter storm worsened.
He trudged through the snow, into a new town,
small and quaint.
There was an abandoned church at the edge
of the main road, a bit broken down, but the
roof held firm against the onslaught of ice
and wind, so the Plague Doctor made it his
new home for the next 12 days, working quietly
and staying out of sight.
Day 53 to 57.
On the eve of the Plague Doctor's 53rd day
on the run from the SCP Foundation, he was
stirred from his work by the sound of a choir
of beautiful voices outside.
He looked, to find a group of Christmas Carolers
singing together, the rows of houses along
the streets covered in colorful lights and
glittering decorations.
Wanting to get a little closer to the music,
the Doctor left his hiding spot for the first
time in nearly two weeks.
But as the choir saw a strangely shaped dark
shadow, emerging from the abandoned church,
they screamed and scattered in every direction.
One of them yelled something about "the Krampus"
as they went.
Frightened by the whole interaction, SCP-049
found himself a new spot, under a bridge.
It was cold, but isolated.
At least, it was for five days.
Day 58.
On day 58, a group of local teenagers, rowdy
and looking to make some trouble, spotted
the Plague Doctor squatting under the bridge.
They pelted him with snowballs, laughing.
Before he could do anything about it, fortunately
for the teens, they ran back to their car
and sped away.
Drenched in ice and cold water, miserable,
and irritated, the Plague Doctor searched
for another place to stay.
Day 59 to Day 84
The Plague Doctor was able to slip into another
relatively quiet building: the local community
theatre, which happened to be an old opera
house repurposed as the site of volunteer-run
musicals.
While the townsfolk began rehearsals for their
production of The Phantom of the Opera, the
Plague Doctor watched from above, hiding in
the shadows.
Every so often, the stagehand would catch
a glimpse of a cape, the silhouette of a face,
a pair of dark eyes, but no one believed her
when she tried to tell them that the Phantom
was real.
At least, until a handyman went up into the
rafters to install some lights, and saw the
Plague Doctor for himself.
Then, it was time for him to flee to a new
town.
DAY 85 TO DAY 89
On Day 85, the Plague Doctor climbed up onto
the roof of a dark house to avoid a particularly
aggressive dog, and let himself in through
the attic window.
The next morning, a little girl came up into
the attic in search of a lost toy, and found
him there.
He waited for her to scream, but she didn't.
She introduced herself as Abby, and asked
if he would like some cookies and milk.
He accepted her gracious offer, and the two
visited with each other for several days,
until Abby's parents asked who she was talking
to.
They didn't take it well when she answered,
"The bird man in the attic."
DAY 90
On Day 90, Abby's parents called the police,
who, having been warned to look out for a
man in a "bird mask," got in touch with their
contacts at the SCP Foundation.
Feeling the authorities closing in, SCP-049
took to the wilderness once more.
DAY 91 T0 DAY 99
Though the air was still painfully cold, The
Plague Doctor managed to set up camp, using
tools from his bag to build a fire and construct
a makeshift tent.
He stayed there for three days before intending
to move on and throw the Foundation off of
his trail, but he was slowed by the appearance
of a group of hikers, bundled up against the
Winter weather and exploring the woods.
Afraid he couldn't trust them, the Doctor
touched one, to convince him to leave.
The man fell to the ground, dead, and as his
companions ran away screaming, the Doctor
vowed to cure him.
Working against the inopportune conditions,
it took him five more days to reanimate the
hiker.
DAY 100
On Day 100 of his time on the lam, the Foundation
finally closed in.
The Plague Doctor was just stitching up a
large incision in his patient's chest, when
he heard the click of a gun behind him.
"Come with us peacefully, and we won't have
to sedate you," the officer said.
With a heavy sigh, the Plague Doctor held
up his hands, stepping back from his patient
just as its undead body sat up, blinking its
unseeing eyes.
"Very well.
I will go back.
To tell you the truth, gentlemen, this has
all been a bit too much trouble.
I could use the rest."
Somewhere, caught between parallel dimensions,
is the containment breach to end all containment
breaches.
Countless unnumbered and nameless anomalies
on a warpath to destroy what has become of
a now-unrepentantly evil Foundation.
A testing site rendered distorted and unstable
under the power of countless reality-warping
objects, and me caught in the middle of it.
You’re probably wondering how I got here.
Well, for starters, I’m what is known as
an anomaly.
If I can see something, I can crush it, using
my brain.
I guess you’d say I have a form of telekinesis,
but fine control or remote levitation are
not my forte.
I’m not sure who I was before the GOC apprehended
and brought me here to this strange place.
A place ruled by a cruel man named Eliott
Emerson and the even crueler Foundation that
he directed.
A place called Site-13, and as for the rest
of us contained here, we don’t get numbers.
The only name I have is the one I gave myself.
If I'm destined to be trapped in this infernal
place by a man named Emerson, I may as well
self-identify as his equal and opposite.
You can call me Thoreau, and this is the story
of how I managed to survive 100 days in Site-13…
well, after everything went haywire.
Here goes nothing…
Day 1.
Like I said before, this all began with the
containment breach to end all containment
breaches.
It is chaos in the hallways, with anomalies
running rampant everywhere.
Most are taking revenge on the guards and
researchers, but not every one of the unnumbered
is in solidarity.
The crystal butterflies and the memetic scribe
are indiscriminately going after anything
that isn’t them, including each other.
As for me, I’m wearing a specialized helmet
that keeps me blindfolded.
It’s a power suppressant, since my anomalous
ability only works on things I can see clearly.
I’d love to remove it, but there’s no
way to find out which guard has clearance
to deactivate my headgear when things are
this manic.
As much as I’d love to celebrate the reckoning
of Site-13, I decided it was better to stay
inside my cell for the day.
Let the record show that if The Foundation
or the GOC do crack down on this, I was well-behaved
during the breach.
Day 2.
It’s gotten marginally quieter out there.
I don’t think the fighting has stopped as
much as it has moved out of the halls where
I’ve been contained.
The Foundation hasn’t dropped off any more
rations today, so I start to think that maybe
this really was the big one.
What if everyone somehow got out?
I started to wonder about some of my fellow
anomalous humanoids and if the containment
breach had given them a chance.
I don’t really know what they look like
because most of the time, I’m forced to
wear a blindfold to suppress my powers, but
I have been able to pick up a few hints through
listening.
There’s a clown named Bobble, he was already
here when I arrived.
And no, he’s not a guy dressed as a clown,
but like a genuine actual clown.
He’s nice enough, but I get the impression
he’d be a bad influence on kids if there
were any here.
Other than Elijah, of course.
He’s known as the Leech Boy since he can
drain the blood from people with his hands.
Scary stuff, really.
I don’t dislike either of them, but I’d
rather not take my chances running into them
during a containment breach.
I guess I'll wait this one out a bit longer.
I had water from the containment unit sink
if I needed to sate my thirst and a day without
a meal wasn’t exactly something new.
Day 3.
I felt a strange rumbling in the air this
morning, like everything in the entire universe
was picked up and dropped back down somewhere
else.
I don’t know how else to describe it.
I once heard some of the guards talking about
a reality-bending machine called the Thresher
on the lower levels.
Could it be the work of that thing?
Day 4.
My old friend Bobble The Clown actually came
through for me.
He has taken up residence in the digital interface
of my cell and is giving me details of what
is happening out there.
The funniest thing about this clown is that
he lives inside of electronic devices.
Bobble was never threatened by my abilities
because they only work on the physical world.
The most I could do to him is crush a television
set where he was dwelling.
Our friendship is based on the fact that the
two of us are among the only things in Site-13
that couldn’t cause harm to each other.
And sadly, I think that my list of enemies
is much higher than Bobble’s.
And a lot of the things out there might hold
a grudge.
The reason I haven’t been thrown into the
fire is that my matter compression ability
is useful to the Foundation.
I’m not proud to admit it, but I’ve agreed
multiple times to use my abilities to bring
some of my fellow anomalies, particularly
the larger ones, down a manageable size for
disposal.
My reward for this is that I’m not subject
to some of the more deadly experiments here,
though it's not like these evil, unethical
scientists can resist some light torture.
Did I mention how much these people hate anomalies?
Because make no mistake, they hate us a lot.
Bobble said he couldn’t stick around, but
that there was an untouched supply of rations
a few cells down that I – as an organism
that needs to eat to survive – should go
and find.
Even with the blindfold it shouldn’t be
too easy for me to get there.
I’ll think about going tomorrow.
Day 4.
As I felt my way through the hallway to the
other cell, I could tell that things had gone
really off the deep end.
There were people fused into the walls, no
doubt because of one of the other anomalies,
and I had no idea whether or not they were
on my side.
There was no doubt that memetic cognitohazards
were scrawled all over the surfaces of the
facility as well.
If The Scribe had truly been on the loose,
he’d definitely have made those brain-destroying
symbols he always did.
Maybe my current lack of vision was a good
thing.
Especially because spending so much of my
time blind had enhanced my sense of smell.
From the inside of a nearby open cell, I caught
wind of a tray of day-old Foundation rations.
And what luck, they were the same kind usually
given to humanoid anomalies like me.
These must have been the ones that Bobble
had mentioned.
I settled into this new cell and enjoyed my
first full meal in days.
Day 5
With the power-suppressing device still firmly
on my head, getting out of here seemed like
a pipe dream.
I spent the day thinking about the only other
person in Site-13 who was kind to me: Dr.
Hadley.
She was a researcher who took care of some
of the humanoid anomalies.
Even though she’s working with The Foundation,
I get the feeling that she’s actually a
really good person deep down.
Maybe it's the Stockholm Syndrome talking,
but I really wish I could see her face.
She always had sympathy for Elijah - the leech
boy - and saw him as an ordinary kid despite
his blood-draining powers.
I can only hope that both of them are safe.
Day 6.
I continued to make my way across the facility
hugging the wall as tightly as I could.
I could hear weapon fire throughout the facility
and countless anomalies battling it out.
All of a sudden, I was caught off guard when
I heard several footsteps coming towards me.
These must have been foundation personnel,
I thought.
A shot rang out, and I was hit directly in
my headgear by some kind of piercing round.
Fortunately, the suppression device was strong
enough to take the hit for me, so I didn’t
take direct damage, and it was equally fortunate
that being shot at had caused it to malfunction.
I could now remove the headgear and blindfold
and stare down the group of armed Foundation
guards in front of me.
“It’s The Crusher!”
One of them shouted.
“My name is Thoreau,” I responded.
I didn’t give them a chance to fire again,
and using my ability to defend myself was
the only way out.
After all the anomalies I had compressed at
their orders, doing the same to Emerson’s
forces came all too naturally.
To them, we were merely objects.
Things to be used up before we’re incinerated.
Whether we’re human, inhuman, or something
entirely indescribable: It makes no difference
to Emerson and his underlings, since all of
us are going to the same place.
After that encounter with the guards, I decided
that I wouldn’t use my powers to harm my
fellow anomaly.
We had all endured so much in Site-13 that
it felt needlessly brutal to let the one thing
that I had in common with the other prisoners
be a weapon against them.
I couldn’t guarantee that all of the other
anomalies would treat me the same way, but
the idea of living by that principle filled
me with a sense of purpose.
From now on, it was me against Site-13.
I would survive and escape to the outside
world.
Day 7.
To my surprise, there was a mundane vending
machine in this terrible place.
I used my powers to break into it: raking
in the delicious bounty of chips, protein
bars, and fruit snacks.
This stash would take care of my sustenance
needs for a while, so I stored them in a military
pack I had taken from one of the guards I
had fought with the other day.
Day 8.
I began to realize that the rooms I was traveling
through were repeating themselves.
It was hard to really notice at first, with
all the cognitohazards I was trying to avoid,
but it seemed like Site-13 was reshuffling
itself in a way that had made my progress
through it completely circuitous.
While this meant that my encounters with dangerous
anomalies and guards had been basically nonexistent,
it also meant that I wasn’t making any progress
towards escape.
Day 9-14.
Yup, I’m officially stuck in a loop now.
This was probably unavoidable even if I had
a mental map of the facility or even a physical
map.
Reality is so broken by the effects of the
Thresher that I don’t even know if the rest
of Site-13 even still exists.
I honestly wouldn’t be that upset if Director
Emerson and the rest of the Foundation personnel
had been flung into oblivion.
That would be worth it even if I spent the
rest of my days here wandering around and
eating vending machine food.
Day 15.
I gained access to a new area of the facility,
only to find that it was a stairwell filled
with a terrifying black gooey substance.
I had no idea what this stuff was, but perhaps
it was best not to touch it.
Yeah, that would definitely be for the best.
Still, there were stairs going away from the
goo which could lead me closer to an exit,
so I decided to take that risk and sprint
up to a higher level.
As if waiting for a cue, the liquid began
to rise as soon as I set foot in the stairwell.
I climbed the stairs as fast as I could, but
this stuff was determined.
I thought I could slow it down by crushing
some of the stairs, but using my powers caused
some of the substance to splash onto my hand.
It didn’t hurt, but now my hand had a hole
directly through the palm.
I could still feel everything, but the affected
area was now see-through.
Freaky, but it definitely could have been
worse.
I made out of the stairwell otherwise intact,
and thankfully the new floor I found myself
on wasn’t anywhere I had been before.
There were giant leeches everywhere, crawling
through cracks in the wall.
Did Elijah do this?
Day 16-27.
I continued making my way through the unexplored
sections, encountering a lot of the remains
of dead guards but no fellow anomalies besides
the leeches.
I made a point of not getting too close to
them, and they didn’t seem to bother me
either.
Most of the leeches seemed content to drink
the blood from the corpses of which there
were plenty.
There were fewer cognitohazards, and I was
grateful for that.
I managed to find and crush a few more vending
machines to restock my food supplies.
Compared to the rations I had been fed since
I was first brought here, these snacks practically
tasted like gourmet food.
On day 28.
Bobble found me again, or rather I found him.
He was inside of a laptop in one of the abandoned
research offices.
We compared notes, and it gave me some idea
of what happened that caused so many of us
to escape.
Apparently, Dr. Hadley had stood up to Emerson
and sabotaged the incinerator.
I guess she truly was a good person.
I’ll have to thank her personally if I happen
to find her still alive somewhere in all of
this.
It could have also been her who activated
the Thresher machine, but I wouldn’t put
it past Emerson to do the same.
Of course, he’d have done so in an effort
to take the rest of us with him.
Isn’t it remarkable that the people we think
we can trust and the people who hold us prisoner
might wind up taking the same action for completely
different reasons?
It could be that my embarrassing little crush
on Dr. Hadley was stopping me from seeing
the bigger picture.
In any case, I thanked Bobble and pressed
onward.
Day 29-39.
While the reshuffling of the hallways and
rooms has considerably slowed down my exploration
of Site-13, I can safely say that I’m making
progress towards finding some kind of way
out.
I’ve come to realize that the further I
get from the lower levels where the Thresher
is at its most powerful, the more stable the
facility’s layout becomes.
If I can make it to the rooftop, then I’m
as good as free.
So my guiding philosophy has become “onwards
and upwards.”
Day 40.
Now, this is unexpected!
I was confronted by another group of armed
Foundation personnel – different uniforms
- one of the Mobile Task Forces, I think – but
instead of shooting me, they just started
asking questions.
The most confusing of which was…
“What is your object class and SCP designation
number?”
I had no idea how to answer.
Were things that different in the other containment
sites?
Site-13 had never given us numbers or formal
classifications beyond simple nicknames derived
from our anomalous properties.
I wasn’t sure what was going on, but I also
didn’t want to risk getting put back into
containment.
I couldn’t be sure this wasn’t some kind
of foundation trick or I hadn’t somehow
lost my mind because of some cognitohazard
I’d accidentally glimpsed.
I crushed a doorway using my powers and ran
for it.
A few shots echoed behind me, but the apparent
leader of the mobile task force called for
them to hold their fire.
Whoever these people were, they definitely
weren’t with Emerson.
Day 41-52.
If the leeches, repeating staircases, and
occasional hostile anomalies weren’t enough,
now I have to deal with these alternative
Foundation personnel poking around here.
It was one thing to protect myself from Site-13’s
dedicated guards, since they’d been responsible
for holding me captive, but my conscience
was telling me not to attack these new mobile
task agents.
Instead, I hid from them as well as I could,
running to another area whenever I was discovered.
I can’t remember where I heard it from,
but I know there’s some old saying about
great power and great responsibility.
Point is, I didn’t want to have the responsibility
of having used my powers to hurt people who
didn’t deserve it.
Still, it seemed like many of the anomalies
didn’t feel the same way.
From what I observed during my circuitous
route around the facility, I could tell that
these mobile task force agents were suffering
losses.
Day 53.
On Day 53, I found a lone agent huddled in
a fetal position against the wall of one of
the containment corridors.
It seemed that no other members of their squad
were present, so either they had been separated
in the madness of Site-13, or they were the
sole survivor.
Either way, I felt sympathetic, so I approached
them in an effort to communicate.
What I learned during this conversation absolutely
blew my mind.
It turned out that the Thresher activation
had caused Site-13 to literally jump universes
and wind up in a timeline where the Foundation
and the GOC had never joined forces.
In this reality, The Foundation was a comparatively
benevolent organization that only sought to
secure, contain, and protect anomalies.
It rarely destroyed anomalous beings unless
those beings posed an existential threat to
other life.
According to the agent I spoke to, if a humanoid
anomaly like me were to be contained by this
version of the organization, I’d most likely
be given free room and board and three meals
a day.
Even if freedom was my ultimate goal, I couldn’t
say that life didn’t tempt me.
I agreed to help this Foundation agent find
the rest of their team, as long as they were
telling the truth.
Day 54-67.
The mobile task force agent and I worked together
to search the facility for other Foundation
personnel - not ones on the payroll of Site-13,
I should clarify.
It was nice having someone to talk to, even
if they recoiled in fear when I mentioned
my best friend was a clown.
I guess a lot of people in this dimension
have an irrational fear of clowns.
By the way, my new friend said that their
name was Agent Ben Mcdowell, and apparently
Site-13 was the most dangerous site that their
task force had ever been deployed into.
I couldn’t say that I wasn’t honored,
especially after all this place had put me
through.
But the nightmare was far from over because
on Day 68…
Oh god, Day 68.
… the leeches surrounded us and were out
for blood.
Agent Mcdowell had only limited ammunition,
and I was still incredibly hesitant to use
my powers on other anomalies.
Of course, my resolve was about to get pushed
to its breaking point as an enormous mutated
leech arrived at our location.
It was biggest anomaly I’d ever seen and
yet there was something uncannily familiar
about it.
Elijah?
Could it be?
The super leech lashed out at Agent McDowell
with its huge tentacles and pulled them into
its terrible toothy mouth.
I ran away as fast as I could.
Should I have felt bad that I had left my
new ally behind with a giant monstrous anomaly?
Yes, I was only human after all.
But self-preservation had kicked in at the
time, and my mind hadn’t fully accepted
that I should be protecting someone dressed
in a Foundation uniform over another anomaly.
Sorry, Agent Mcdowell.
At the very least, I won’t forget your kindness.
Day 69-84.
I was on my own again, wandering through the
facility as it twisted and changed.
Trapped in a dimension that wasn’t my own,
with freedom feeling even less possible now
that I knew there was an entirely different
Foundation after me now.
I never saw Elijah again - or rather, the
horrific thing that Elijah had become.
I made a guess, grimly, that Dr. Hadley was
probably gone by now.
So many lives had been lost because of the
cruelty of Site Director Eliott Emerson.
If I found him, I would make sure that he
paid for the hell he put us through.
Day 85.
On Day 85, I did find him.
There he was, screaming as he was pulled along
the wheel-like face of a terrifying many-armed
god.
I couldn’t stare too long because the wheel
was covered in runes that were cognitohazards,
but I got a good enough look.
The man responsible for all of this was now
being tormented himself.
I wouldn’t have been capable of a better
punishment on my own, so I left him to his
fate.
Day 86-100
It took me fifteen more days of searching
for staircases before I made it to the rooftop
of site-13.
When I got there, a Foundation helicopter
was waiting for me.
And fortunately, it was the foundation of
this new dimension.
One that would provide food and shelter for
me like a human deserves and never subject
me to experiments against my will.
As I watched Site-13 get farther away from
inside the helicopter, a smile crossed my
face for the first time in 100 days.
I made it?
I actually made it?
I’m still alive, by some miracle – or
maybe by sheer luck – I made it to the end
of my sentence.
Over three months of the most horrific work
I’ve ever had to do, with no other alternative.
But it’s paid off, because any minute now,
they’ll be coming into the dorm to let me
go.
I can walk out of here with my head up.
I can’t wait to get out of these orange
overalls that I’ve had to live in since
I arrived.
It seems like so much longer, in all honesty.
The only way I’ve been able to keep track
of how many days I’ve been stuck here is
by putting tally marks on the wall next to
my dormitory bed.
A hundred, I’ve been a member of D-Class
personnel for the SCP Foundation for the last
one hundred days.
And here’s how I survived…
They didn’t waste any time early on; I’ll
give the Foundation that.
I’d barely been out of my sentencing hearing
for a few days.
Put on trial and convicted for a crime I didn’t
even commit.
There had been a string of murders, and someone
who had either been involved or was responsible
laid the blame on me.
But whoever they were, they had powerful friends.
The cops were in on it, planting evidence
to frame me and make it look like I was guilty
when I was really innocent.
That’s what landed me in prison, serving
a sentence of twenty-five years to life behind
bars.
And it was during my first week of incarceration
that he showed up.
The recruitment specialist, a clean-cut, blunt,
Agent Smith type came to visit me.
I hadn’t even been in prison long enough
to have visitor privileges, but the shady
agent seemed to know which strings to pull
in order to ask me an important question:
“What would you do to get out of here?”
he’d said.
To which my answer was “Anything.”
That was my first mistake.
Immediately, the next day I received a letter
detailing more about what exactly Agent Smith
was offering.
It was folded and hidden in the spine of a
book that a guard handed me during reading
hour.
Unfolding the message, it all felt like an
old-school covert spy tactic.
“To Mr Emil Carker,” the letter read.
“We understand that you recently received
a criminal conviction.
There are two options currently before you,
as detailed below.
One: you can serve out the remainder of your
sentence in prison.
Or two: you can be released into the care
of our organization.
While with us, you will be helping to further
scientific advancements through hard work.
We have devised a system that allows convicts
such as yourself to perform a vital role within
our organization, in return for a reduction
in their prison sentences.
“We have no interest in or intention of
determining any guilt for the crimes for which
you are currently convicted.
We merely seek to present this opportunity
to you.
We ask that you destroy this letter once you
have finished reading.
Should you be interested in our offer, then
please recite the phrase ‘it’s a yes’
to a prison guard with the badge number: 47890.”
Naturally, as cryptic as an offer like that
was, I didn’t need much time to mull it
over.
I was trapped in prison for something I didn’t
do, with no way to appeal for my freedom or
prove my innocence.
So, taking up a mysterious job opportunity
from a shadowy group seemed like a much better
alternative at the time.
After all, I could either work off my sentence
through employment, or rot away in a cell
for the next two and half decades at minimum.
All I had to do next was find the right guard.
I tried not to make it obvious that I was
eyeing every prison guard’s badge number
as they stood around, keeping a close eye
on me and the other inmates.
But it was while out in the yard that I saw
him: number 47890.
I had gone to bed with a knot in my stomach.
Hours earlier, I had done exactly as the letter
said and approached the guard, making sure
I was close enough for him to hear me, but
trying to make it clear that I wasn’t looking
tor start any trouble either.
“It’s a yes,” I told him.
In response, 47890 had furrowed his brow and
scrunched his mustache, seemingly in disgust.
“Back up, inmate,” he commanded sharply.
I backed away with my hands raised, confused
as to what had just happened.
I spent the entire rest of the day thinking
about it; maybe the note had been a prank,
some kind of initiation, seeing as I was the
newest prisoner.
But that didn’t explain the agent who had
shown up before.
What was going on?
The questions that were spinning around in
my head eventually wore me out.
And while I slept, that’s when someone put
a bag over my head, drugged me, and snuck
me out of prison.
When I woke up, I was somewhere new, a room
filled with other convicts.
Although not many of them seemed to have come
from the same prison I had been sentenced
to; plenty were sporting different jumpsuits,
but their gruff demeanors told me all I needed
to about them.
I was surrounded by a more violent breed of
criminal, some of the worst of the absolute
worst.
The atmosphere in this pen full of murderers
and monsters was so tense that it felt like
the slightest accidental bump could explode
into a full-blown fight.
Suddenly, a hatch in the ceiling opened, and
a pile of clothes came thumping down from
above.
It was a mass of orange, enough matching overalls
for every inmate in the room.
Of course, I held back from the initial clamor
some of the others made, grabbing their new
prison garb, snatching orange overalls from
each other, and arguing.
When I eventually got mine, I noticed an unfamiliar
logo emblazoned on the front of the uniform.
After being made to wait a whole day in the
pen, the other prisoners and I were filed
out of the room by heavily armed security
guards.
We were all directed towards a hall, nobody
was daring enough to challenge the officers,
even the more violent among the prisoners.
I spotted that the guard’s uniforms bore
the same insignia as the overalls we’d been
made to wear.
It must’ve been the logo of the mysterious
organization that had offered me employment.
We were given an orientation talk led by someone
who introduced themselves as a Junior Assistant
Researcher.
They explained that our current location was
highly classified, as was the true identity
of the group that had arranged for us to be
released.
All we were told was that this was an unspecified
form of research facility, and that we had
to cooperate with the facility’s staff if
we wanted to secure our release.
It seemed straightforward enough, although
the Junior Assistant Researcher seemed to
make a lot of jokes about us dying during
these tests.
I think they hoped it would alleviate some
of the tension…
it didn’t.
After sitting through the orientation talk,
I still had more questions than answers.
The one thing I had learned was that being
tattooed hurt.
Exiting the hall, the other prisoners and
I had been directed to get a designation number
tattooed on our wrist and across our chest.
When someone had asked why the chest, the
Researcher conducting orientation had answered:
“Well, in the event of an explosion, it's
most likely that it'll be the largest intact
chunk of meat left.”
This was another of their ‘jokes’.
Still feeling sore as my tattoo healed, I
read the number now permanently inked onto
my body: D-2152.
‘D-Class Personnel’ that’s what they
called us now.
We were directed into a dormitory, a lot less
cramped than my old cell.
But still, being surrounded by violent criminals
when I knew I didn’t belong there, it felt
no less isolating.
One of them, who took the bunk next to mine,
introduced himself to me as ‘Shiv’.
Worried he might try to kill me, I did my
best to be friendly towards him.
Shiv and I didn’t exactly bond, but more
sprung up conversations because there was
little else to do.
I was still worried about some of the flippant
comments made about us all dying, until he
pointed out something far stranger.
“Don’t you wonder why they’re making
us wait?” he asked.
And the moment he mentioned it, I did start
to wonder about that.
It seemed odd that this organization had wasted
little time in getting us all here.
It had only been a week ago that I entered
my prison cell for the first time, now I was
here.
“I think it’s their way of telling us,”
Shiv went on.
“That we aren’t here to be helpful, to
be a workforce for them.
They’ve brought us all here to die.”
That comment made me look around, and actually
acknowledge the people I was trapped with.
They were some of the worst criminals imaginable,
irredeemable killers.
Would this organization really let those people
back out into the world after helping out
with a few tests?
I’d soon find out, because Day 8 was the
last day before I found myself working directly
for the SCP Foundation.
I picked up the name from a few places around
the facility; nametags, lab coats, and security
uniforms, always with the same logo.
Me and the other D-Class personnel were woken
up early in the morning by a bell and issued
with assignments.
From the very first day the work started,
I noticed that not all the others came back
to the dorm at the end of the day.
Shiv was one of those.
My tasks mostly consisted of cleaning up with
a mop, hosing down empty testing chambers
that had a worrying amount of blood sprayed
over the walls and floors.
The regiments were strict, and I made sure
to do exactly what was asked of me to avoid
causing any trouble.
It felt a lot like being back in prison, but
with the only added caveat of being able to
move around the facility, even if it was to
go and wipe up the Foundation’s mess.
Although the other classes of personnel didn’t
seem to take kindly to my help, making snide
comments as they passed me in the hallways.
We had been told not to address the other
staff unless spoken to, which was frustrating.
I certainly had a few things I would’ve
liked to say to them.
After two and a half weeks without so much
as a hint of any trouble, I was given my first
testing assignment that wasn’t just cleaning
up.
You would think that would be exciting, but
having seen some of the carnage left behind
after other tests, I was anything but eager
to take part.
Luckily for me, and pretty surprisingly, my
first test was pretty straightforward.
I was shown to a room containing a white bowl
decorated with light blue flowers that the
researchers referred to as SCP-348.
I had received a nasty splinter from my mop’s
handle the day before, and was instructed
to sit down and eat from the bowl, which was
filled with soup.
Naturally, I eagerly ate it all, despite how
bitter it tasted.
It was better than the food from the D-Class
canteen at least.
But when I finished, I noticed a message had
appeared at the bottom of SCP-348.
It read:
“I don’t believe you were framed.
Goodbye, son.”
After that, it was as if the floodgates had
been opened, and every day I was asked to
do another test with a new SCP.
Most were harmless anomalous creatures or
objects, like one of the bigger experiments
I was involved in, which focused on SCP-999,
this friendly gelatinous orange blob.
Electrodes were hooked up to me while I just
sat calmly in a room with SCP-999.
Being around it made me feel great, the best
I had felt since arriving and joining D-Class.
Although I did hear one of the researchers
making the comment that SCP-999 was ‘not
quite ready yet’.
Even so, the Tickle Monster had given me a
new positive outlook on my role at the Foundation.
It was odd work, but I could find a rhythm
to it that would hopefully make the time pass
by a little quicker.
And if it meant getting out, it was worth
all the dirty looks from other classes of
personnel.
This was an outlook I didn’t want to lose.
After a month, we were told to take a pill
that the guards handed out to us, something
called an amnestic that would make us all
forget the previous month.
But, wanting to hang on to my newfound optimism,
I secretly flushed mine down a toilet.
In hindsight, I should have taken it.
My next big test quickly brought me back down
a peg.
I was handed a katana, SCP-572, and instantly
felt like I was unstoppable.
The sword made me believe I was a powerful
warrior, as if I could maybe fight my way
out of the Foundation facility with ease.
Unfortunately, the moment I tried to use it
didn’t lead to freedom.
I had an accident, broke my arm and suffered
a series of internal fractures, all while
the research team mocked me.
Embarrassed, I felt like a total laughing
stock.
Things only got worse from there.
I had barely set foot outside of the infirmary
before a different team of personnel told
me I was going to be assisting them with an
important task.
They dragged me to an old wooden door after
briefly explaining what was going on; although
I struggled to keep up.
Beyond the door – which they called SCP-2317
– was a vast salt pan.
Following their instructions, I acted as an
assistant to the rest of the team as they
performed a strange ritual.
I had to scatter a mix of holy water and chicken
blood around a circle of seven stone pillars,
then recite:
“Blood for the Old Gods, Water for the New
King.”
It was an unusual practice, to say the least,
but apparently, I was helping keep a powerful,
vengeful demigod imprisoned.
That did little to soften the news that I
heard when we returned through SCP-2317.
While I was gone, one of the Foundation’s
security team had been infected by something
known as SCP-2193, a phenomenon that makes
people believe that every month a large group
of D-Class are to be ‘terminated’.
When I heard, I actually considered taking
my amnestic for this month to forget just
how many had been killed…
It had been a whole two months since I had
actively started work as part of D-Class Personnel,
and there weren’t many of my fellow prisoners
left.
I was sent for a mandatory psychological evaluation;
the Foundation wanted to know if I would still
be able to perform tests for them.
I doubted it came from a place of actual concern,
it’s not like they cared all that much if
the things I had seen were taking a toll on
me.
Sitting across from the researcher performing
my evaluation, I did my best impression of
a normal person.
I had to pretend like none of it was getting
to me, all the horrors and the close brush
I’d almost had with death by Monthly Termination.
I wouldn’t have lied about it normally,
But I’d been told I had a month left before
I was due to be released.
Apparently, not many D-Class made it that
far, given the dangerous nature of testing.
All I could think about was how good it would
feel to eat real food again; I started to
daydream about getting a cheeseburger on my
first day out.
Almost instantly, my hopes for freedom were
dashed the very next day.
I was told I’d be going on a longer assignment,
this time it would be an expedition into an
anomalous location called SCP-432.
The Foundation’s researchers outfitted me
with a flashlight, plus extra batteries.
A headset and microphone linked to their control
center were placed over my ear, along with
a camera unit mounted on my shoulder; they
said it would wirelessly transmit back to
them, and they’d see what I saw.
I was also given a couple of bottles of water,
some energy bars, and a few sticks of luminous
marker chalk.
But when they had said ‘anomalous location’,
the last thing I’d been expecting was to
climb into a rusty metal cabinet.
The next two weeks were like living inside
a nightmare.
Inside the cabinet was a huge maze, a literal
labyrinth all made out of the same rusted
steel of the exterior of SCP-432.
It was so dark, even with the use of my flashlight
and the few lightbulbs affixed to some of
the walls within the Cabinet Maze.
Before long, I ended up losing my bearings,
lost with no way out.
But being trapped in the maze and the dark
wasn’t even the worst parts.
There was something else in the labyrinth,
some kind of creature lurking through the
metal corridors.
My flashlight eventually ran out of power,
so I never actually saw it, but every time
I tried to sleep, I’d just lay awake, listening
to its growls.
I couldn’t help what kind of horrible thing
was out there, and might be looming over me
in the dark.
Even when I opened my eyes, I still wouldn’t
get to see it.
Eventually, another D-Class was sent into
SCP-432.
By some miracle, he was able to not only find
me, but guide me back to the entrance of the
Cabinet Maze.
The moment I was free, I yelled at the research
team, demanding they let me go.
I didn’t just mean let out of SCP-432, I
meant free from D-Class, from the Foundation,
from all of it.
I was sent for another psyche evaluation and
deemed to be fine, just suffering from heightened
stress.
When they asked me if I’d been taking my
amnestics, I lied and told them yes.
Ten days before I was set to be released and
they couldn’t help but assign me to one
last test.
“Don’t worry,” a researcher sarcastically
assured me.
“This one will be nice and easy on you,
you’ll just have to jump into a paddling
pool.
You can do that, can’t you, D-2152?”
The paddling pool in question was SCP-120.
Every time a different glow emanated from
it, I was instructed to jump in.
The exact second I did, I found myself transported
somewhere new.
I got The Himalayas on my first go, Greenland
and the Sahara Desert on the next two tries.
Every one of the locations I ended up at had
some kind of Foundation facility established
nearby.
They’d pick me up, and I’d be taken back
to SCP-120 to continue testing.
It felt like I was being deliberately, intentionally
tortured.
The Foundation was giving me these momentary
glimpses of freedom every time I was teleported
by SCP-120.
It was a carrot on the end of a stick that
they were keeping just out of my reach, and
I hated it.
It made me realize that I had never been there
to work for them, being part of D-Class Personnel
wasn’t a job.
All I was to them was a human lab rat.
Now it’s my last day.
They’ve promised me that by the end of today,
I won’t be here anymore.
I just want to be out, done with D-Class for
good.
The Foundation’s researchers have given
me one last, simple test to do before I go.
They said if I do, then I’ll be gone.
All they want me to do is wear this amulet
for someone called Doctor Bright.
How hard can that be?
And they said they’d let me go after this
one last thing, so it can’t be anything
all that bad, right?
Right…?
It doesn’t feel quite real to say this but…
mission accomplished.
I did it, I actually made it through.
My extraction is currently en route, and once
they’re here, I’ll be heading back to
the SCP Foundation.
It doesn’t feel like a hundred days since
this all started, if anything it feels like
a lot longer.
But it’s done now, the mission is finally
over – and now the real work begins.
I’ll be taken in for debriefing when I arrive,
so I’d better get my story straight before
that transport gets here.
Here’s how I Survived 100 Days Infiltrating
the Chaos Insurgency.
It started with a message; a direct request
passed down straight to me from the O5 Council
themselves.
I was shocked initially to receive any communication
from them; the Council were hardly hands-on
bosses, preferring to co-ordinate the Foundation
from a station far, far above mine.
I was part of a Mobile Task Force, used to
being out in the field, so when I got the
message – saying the Council wanted to talk
to me – I wasn’t quite sure what to make
of it.
I went through various different states of
reaction in my head, first being honored that
they had singled me out.
That then turned into worry – had I done
something wrong, or was this some kind of
dismissal from the Foundation?
Was it a performance review?
When it finally came time for me to stand
before the O5 Council, the last thing that
I was expecting to hear was that they had
selected me specially for a dangerous undercover
assignment.
Of course, I had heard of the Chaos Insurgency
before.
Although I was yet to actually encounter them
in the field, the MTFs were all instructed
to keep up to date on who the Foundation’s
enemies were.
As a Group of Interest, it wasn’t hard to
see why they were such a threat.
A heavily armed, clandestine organization
with goals of weaponizing SCPs and achieving
world domination: they sounded like lunatics,
but dangerous lunatics all the same.
That was the first step in my mission: know
your enemy.
I was instructed to familiarise myself with
the Chaos Insurgency, to understand them inside
and out.
While the MTF agent in me wanted to just get
boots to ground and start the real work, this
operation needed a different approach.
And so, I hit the books; or, to put it more
accurately, I began scouring the SCP Foundation’s
database for any and all intel on the Insurgency.
All I could do was sit and read.
Within forty-eight hours of being given my
assignment, I felt like I knew everything
about the Chaos Insurgency back to front,
sideways, upside down, and pretty much any
and every way possible.
So, imagine how disheartened I felt when I
reported my research to the O5 Council, only
to be told that I hadn’t done enough.
Hardly the best feeling, I won’t deny it
stung to hear that my day of research wasn’t
adequate prep for my assignment.
But the Council did have an important point:
this was a covert, deep-cover infiltration
into one of the most dangerous groups that
opposed the Foundation.
Purely memorizing all manner of facts and
figures about the Insurgency, learning of
all their tactical capabilities, reading up
on the various rumors about how they were
founded; all that was just knowledge.
If I wanted to pass myself off as a part of
the Chaos Insurgency and avoid detection,
knowing wasn’t enough.
I had to think like one of them.
The timeline of the mission began to accelerate
rapidly.
I would have to train myself to believe the
Insurgency’s core beliefs as I went along;
events weren’t going to wait for me to ne
ready.
The Council informed me that they were aware
of a double agent working for the Chaos Insurgency
from within the SCP Foundation itself.
Obviously, I had heard rumors that there were
operatives embedded within the ranks of the
Foundation, but what was more surprising was
that the O5 Council seemed to already know
who these agents were.
I had always assumed that these Insurgents
kept their identities a secret, so to hearing
that a particular researcher – Doctor Parsons
– was a known Chaos Insurgency conspirator
and still had a job at the Foundation was
both startling and worrying.
But he provided me a way in, and I assumed
that’s why the O5 Council allowed the Insurgency’s
double agents to remain as ‘undetected’
as they thought they were.
It meant they could be used as tools for the
Foundation’s benefit to get at the Insurgency
– they were double agents, after all.
Doctor Parsons was due to be at the same Foundation
site I was stationed at for only a few days.
The upside of working directly on the orders
of the Council meant that they had the administerial
reach to pull all the necessary strings to
get this duplicitous double agent in the right
place for me to intercept him, but not for
long.
The window of opportunity was only a small
one, I had a short time to get close enough
to Parsons and get him to put me in contact
with his friends at the Chaos Insurgency.
Of course, I had to be tactful about it.
If I came on too strong, there was a strong
chance the double agent would easily detect
that something was off and that his cover
had been blown.
So, the plan was simple: strike up a conversation
with the spy, in a way that wouldn’t arouse
suspicion and would compel him to assist my
joining the Chaos Insurgency.
Actually, ‘simple’ might not have been
the right word.
The day of my confrontation with Parsons I
was uncontrollably nervous.
I could feel myself shaking and silently hoped
that it wasn’t noticeable to anyone looking
at me.
The mess hall, was decided as the best place
I could drum up some kind of conversation
with him.
As I picked up my food tray, I spotted the
doctor taking a seat in a far corner.
Cautiously, I approached and asked if I could
join him.
In the back of my head, I kept reminding myself
I had to play it casual.
If I went in immediately with claiming I felt
the Foundation should be run differently,
then Parsons would smell the deception, and
the whole mission would come apart.
So instead, I started small.
We drummed up a conversation about the quality
of the food the Foundation catering team had
given us – or rather, the lack of quality.
Then we chatted about containment procedures,
and various anomalies that we had each encountered
in our different jobs.
Lunch was wrapping up, we’d both finished
our food and I knew my window was about to
close.
And so, I threw in to conversation:
“You ever get sick of the way they do things?”
The entire next day, I was on edge, worried
that I’d thrown my assignment and alerted
Parsons that the Foundation was aware of his
ties to the Insurgency.
I didn’t leave the Task Force barracks,
confining myself to my quarters.
If I left, there was always a slim chance
of running into Doctor Parsons, or that the
Council would call me in to reprimand how
I handled first contact.
To my surprise, my paranoid thoughts were
broken by a direct message from Parsons.
He mentioned being intrigued by some of our
conversation the previous day, and being disappointed
I hadn’t been in the mess hall this lunchtime
to continue discussing certain aspects.
It felt weirdly nice being friendly, only
to then remember the man was a double agent
for the Chaos Insurgency.
His message went on to suggest we should meet
in private in his office.
And that’s when the tension really hit me.
Either he wanted me dead with no witnesses,
or he had bought my line about disagreeing
with the Foundation’s methods.
I arrived at Parsons’ office at the agreed
time, only to be welcomed warmly by the doctor.
It was instantly disarming, and intentionally
so.
I tried not to fall for it, just in case he
knew what I was really up to.
But at the same time, I couldn’t let it
show.
Doctor Parsons seemed to pick up our discussion
from the other day, immediately talking about
how the SCP Foundation would be better off
putting anomalies to use rather than keeping
them contained.
I was surprised how brazen he was being, but
then again, the Council knew he was a mole,
maybe they had bugged his office, and he hadn’t
realized.
Nodding along, pretending to agree with what
the doctor was saying, the conversation quickly
progressed.
I told Parsons I felt the same, and it was
frustrating to me as an MTF agent, seeing
so many co-workers die in containment breaches
against SCPs.
That was the moment he mentioned he had ‘some
friends I should meet.’
The following night, they came for me while
I slept in the barracks.
I had no idea who had drugged me, although
I suspected it was Doctor Parsons.
He wasn’t there when I woke up though, in
fact, I couldn’t really tell who was at
first.
The combination of the bag over my face and
my head still reeling from whatever had knocked
me out saw to that.
Wherever I was, I didn’t get to see it.
There were figures near me, at least two,
that much I could make out.
Especially when the interrogation started.
They were Chaos Insurgency; their line of
questioning told me that.
Between punches and tasing, their questions
ranged from what I was really up to, to whether
the Foundation had sent me to infiltrate their
organization.
They’d anticipated the Council would use
their own tactics against them, but every
time, no matter how much pain they inflicted,
I denied it.
I wasn’t a mole, I told them over and over
again: I believed what they believed.
After over a week of torture, the bag came
off, and I was greeted by the sight of my
captors in Chaos Insurgency tactical gear.
They informed me that I had passed the initial
phase of their recruitment process, and after
suffering so much, that should have come as
a relief.
My mission to infiltrate them was progressing,
but their interrogation had left me exhausted
and in intense pain.
The pair of Insurgents made it very clear
that I wasn’t one of them though, not yet.
In order to fully join their ranks, they wanted
to send me on an operation with one of their
armed detachments.
If I complied with orders, and made a deliberate
act against the SCP Foundation, that would
tell them that I was ready to become part
of the Chaos Insurgency.
If I refused, or the mission was deemed to
be a failure, it would mean an on-the-spot
execution.
Hiding my reluctance, knowing I wouldn’t
be able to forewarn the Foundation, I agreed.
I spent the next several days with a new group
of Insurgency operatives.
None of them gave me their names, nor any
actionable intel I could pass on to the Council.
I just had to refer to them by their various
Gamma and Beta class numbers, their ranks
within the Chaos Insurgency.
The mission was an extraction; as part of
their efforts to utilize anomalies, the Insurgency
would often launch violent raids on the Foundation
to capture SCPs.
Their target this time was SCP-2800, the Cactusman.
He was mostly harmless save for his spines,
but the group’s leaders, Delta Command,
wanted to force SCP-2800 to join their ranks.
I had to treat it like any other operation
with my MTF, trying to force myself to forget
that I was on the wrong side as we broke into
the Site containing SCP-2800.
He didn’t want to leave, but I hoped that
the Foundation would eventually launch a counter
mission to rescue him.
All that mattered for now was making the Insurgency
see that I could be helpful, and useful to
them.
Sure enough, the Foundation did recover SCP-2800.
And by the time they did, the Chaos Insurgency
had already welcomed me into their ranks.
I’d proven myself and that I shared their
beliefs in utilizing the anomalous to realize
their goals.
During the mission, I had made a point of
showing my experience and skills as an MTF
operative, hoping that would impress them.
It seemed to have done the trick, as I was
made a member of Beta Class, still under the
command of Gamma and the Delta Command above
them.
But it was a start, at least, not as low in
the chain as the Alpha Class were.
They were Insurgency recruits with no experience
dealing with anomalies, and who only joined
to escape their miserable lives.
Delta Command considered Alpha Class expendable,
as if they were little more than just cannon
fodder.
I couldn’t help but feel bad for them, especially
when I realized that the Foundation treated
their D Class exactly the same.
Even the MTFs were mostly foot soldiers to
them…
Now established within the Insurgency’s
ranks, I spent the next two weeks finding
out everything I could about their operations
and reporting back to the O5 Council through
a secure, encrypted channel.
Part of my infiltration mission was to see
if I could locate the Engine, a mysterious
anomalous artifact that had apparently influenced
the earliest members – now Delta Command
– to form the Chaos Insurgency in the first
place.
There was no sign of the Engine anywhere in
the compound I was stationed at.
Then again, its location was likely a closely
guarded secret.
I did, however, encounter one of the anomalies
within the Insurgency’s possession.
It was SCP-1316, what appeared to be an ordinary
and harmless kitten named Lucy.
But in actuality, SCP-1316 was an intelligent
and sophisticated listening device used to
spy on the Foundation and report back to the
Insurgency; I made sure to warn the Council
the moment I found out, letting them know
it wasn’t just double agents being used
to report on Foundation activity.
Just as things were starting to form a regular
pattern, things seemed to start going south.
A few of my ‘fellow’ Insurgents seemed
to mention things in conversation that made
me start to feel paranoid.
They weren’t directly referencing me, but
they talked openly about what they’d do
if they found out the Foundation had tried
to spy on the Insurgency; and none of it was
pleasant.
I spent the rest of the day wracked with worry.
There was no way they could have known I was
communicating with the O5 Council, or that
the only reason I was there had been to gather
intelligence on the Chaos Insurgency.
It could have just been what people talked
about here, although I couldn’t shake my
concern that maybe my cover had been blown,
that this was their subtle way of telling
me the Insurgency was onto me.
The worrying left me no choice, and I raised
my concerns with the Council the first chance
I got.
Unfortunately, the response I received the
following day did little to subdue my worries.
The O5 Council contacted me, reminding me
of the importance of my mission.
I was to infiltrate and report back to them,
find the Engine or at least its location.
There was an extraction planned, arriving
in secret in a month’s time.
That was my time limit, and a warning came
with it:
“If you can’t complete this assignment,
then don’t bother returning to the Foundation,”
the Council told me.
“If you are unsuccessful in carrying out
your objectives, it will be taken as an act
of sedition.
We will consider you an active member of the
Chaos Insurgency, and thus a threat to the
Foundation.”
I was furious, not to mention scared out of
my mind.
The Council was willing to turn their backs
on me if I couldn’t deliver, and if the
Insurgency found out they had a mole in their
ranks, then it sounded like they were ready
to kill me on the spot.
The Insurgency were gearing up for another
mission, this time a more aggressive attack
on the Foundation as opposed to the stealthier
extraction that I’d previously been on.
Surprisingly, that put me more at ease; sure,
it’d be dangerous, but this was what I was
good at.
In the field intensity, combating anomalies.
I could use this as an opportunity to regain
some footing, remind the Chaos Insurgency
what made me useful to them… or so I thought.
The mission was to capture SCP-682, and fit
it with a piece of technology the Insurgency
had tested on SCP-2394, a form of sapient
tree frog.
Their plan was the device would enable them
to control the Hard to Destroy Reptile, meaning
the Insurgency would have an unstoppable,
adaptable killing machine in their arsenal.
The attack on the Foundation site was a bloodbath,
MTFs beset the Insurgents on all sides.
And as for 682…
well, it wasn’t exactly known for coming
quietly without putting up a fight.
Returning from the field, after only a few
days, I was confronted by a higher-up, a member
of Gamma Class that oversaw the Insurgency’s
operations.
He told me that there had been numerous reports
from other operatives, that they hadn’t
seen me killing or even injuring Foundation
personnel during the failed extraction of
SCP-682.
It was true, I was still loyal to the Foundation,
after all.
The people working there were still my co-workers,
even if I was pretending to be an Insurgent.
I’d deliberately missed shots, still using
my weapon in the firefights with MTFs, but
without causing them harm.
I’d hoped nobody in the Insurgency would
notice, but it seemed they had.
I brushed off the accusation, made some excuse
about needing to go for an eye exam and get
contact lenses.
But under the surface were relentless shudders
of panic.
In hindsight, the Gamma officer had told me
this so the Insurgency could see how I reacted,
but at the time, I didn’t realize… and
that played right into their hand.
The next day I was caught while going to send
an urgent SOS message to the O5 Council.
Before I could reach the place I stashed by
encrypted comm device, a group of Chaos Insurgency
Beta class operatives rushed me.
I was bagged again, pulled away kicking and
screaming, and unable to call for help…
Over the next few days, it was like I’d
been sent back in time to the start of my
infiltration.
As the Insurgency tortured me again, I refused
to give in, despite how much I wanted to just
to make the pain stop.
But even then, it didn’t matter.
Their knowledge of the Foundation was greater
than I realized, and the Insurgents were easily
able to crack the encryption of my comm unit.
With that broken, they had access to all the
messages I’d been sending to the O5 Council;
and realizing who had sent me made them change
their interrogation methods.
The Insurgents revealed something I hadn’t
heard before, something the Council had apparently
kept a secret.
The Chaos Insurgency had once been a part
of the SCP Foundation.
I refused to believe it at first, but with
all I’d seen as an MTF agent, even my undercover
mission, it started to make sense.
An off-the-record black ops unit working for
the O5 Council to circumvent the Ethics Committee.
They’d grown disillusioned with how the
Foundation handled its anomalies and broken
away to form… the Chaos Insurgency.
When I accepted that to be true, the Insurgents
brought me to what I had been sent for.
They took me to the Engine.
Now I’m awaiting my extraction transport.
After showing me the device that caused their
earliest founders to splinter off from the
Foundation, the Chaos Insurgency took me several
miles from their compound, to the co-ordinates
the O5 Council had told me to be at.
The Foundation think they’re getting their
agent back, and with me, plenty of intel on
their enemies.
But the Engine showed me the truth.
Showed me the lies and fallacies of the Foundation,
and especially of the O5 Council.
They think they’re getting back their agent…
but I serve the Chaos Insurgency now.
It’s hard to believe it’s been a full
one hundred days since I began my journey
– no, my mission – into the beating heart
of the SCP Foundation.
I, Stathis Stern, risked detection, my safety
and even my own life for this cause, and I’m
sure that makes you wonder why on Earth I’d
be foolhardy enough to put so much on the
line.
Well, my reason is the best – no, the only
– reason that matters: for the sake of art.
I decided early on that recording my findings
was essential, both for posterity and so that
the art world may know just how dedicated
I have been in my pursuit of true inspiration.
It all started over three months ago, that
was when I first managed to embed myself in
the SCP Foundation.
Naturally, I never would have jumped at the
idea of having to fraternize with the likes
of the Chaos Insurgency.
Their methods are far too brutal, their organization
seeped in violence that trivializes my own
pursuit of a deeper meaning.
But even I have to admit, the Insurgency’s
methodology can yield results.
They arranged for a convenient ‘accident’
to befall a lower-level researcher, after
they returned home from Site-19; the SCP Foundation’s
largest and most infamous facility, home to
many of their equally-infamous anomalies.
Thanks to a falsified identity and phony transfer
order from the Insurgency, I was able to slip
into Site-19 undetected, so that I could begin
my search.
The subterfuge was, at first, easy to maintain.
I looked the part, obviously.
A lab coat and name badge, so versatile and
yet completely unassuming.
I was visible and still imperceptible to the
rest of the Foundation’s personnel; as far
as they knew, I was just the latest transfer
to Site-19.
As I spent the day getting my bearings, not
one of them could have possibly known my true
intention.
My goal was simple and twofold.
First and foremost: I had long felt I deserved
to be accepted as a member of the art collective
known as ‘AWCY?’
or ‘Are We Cool Yet?’.
Since the nineteenth century, they have been
championing the creation and exhibition of
anomalous artwork, truly pushing the boundaries
of what can be considered artistic expression
despite the Foundation’s attempts to censor
AWCY’s transcendent art.
I had admired their mission statement from
afar, for a number of years, and strived to
achieve much the same in my own artwork.
However, none of my previous pieces quite
met the collective’s anomalous pedigree.
I know a way to change that, though…
Blending in at Site-19 proved to be fairly
simple; as long as you stride around with
purpose, few will question what you’re doing.
With my head in a notebook, or a look of conviction
on my face, I could freely make my way around
the facility.
But why, you might wonder?
What was the actual intention behind my undercover
mission?
Well, the answer lies in the second half of
my goal: recognition.
Not just notoriety and acceptance into the
ranks of AWCY, but fame throughout the anomalous
art world – and all the perks that could
come with.
Of course, the main hurdle to overcome was
I needed to create a piece of art that was
anomalous in its nature.
And so, rather than wait for inspiration and
materials to fall into my lap, I chose to
instead seek out what I needed.
The anomalies on offer at Site-19 were abundant,
and knowing where to start was tricky.
I made the decision, while still getting accustomed
to my new surroundings, that I would start
wherever I felt the most drawn to.
Before the end of my first week in Site-19,
I felt the first pull of an anomaly, and uncovered
it in the most unlikely of places.
During the day, most of the Foundation living
quarters are empty, meaning I could sneak
around there undetected.
It was in the personal bathroom of one Foundation
doctor that I found SCP-063.
To the untrained eye, the anomaly appears
to be an ordinary toothbrush, save for the
wording stenciled into its pale blue plastic:
“The World’s Best Tothbrush”.
Of course, examining it closer, I learned
of its ability to cleave through inorganic
matter like a hot knife through butter.
It was quite the shock, slicing the porcelain
of the bathroom’s sink by accident.
That would have led to my detection, had I
not left soon after.
But I reflected on the toothbrush – or ‘Tothbrush’
– and what it could possibly represent.
Perhaps an acknowledgment of rituals, and
their importance to human health.
Yet, at the same time, being sharp enough
to cut anything not organic – anything not
human – maybe SCP-063 was meant to symbolize
the possible dangers of habitual behaviors.
The next day, I was able to bear witness to
an anomalous piece I had only ever heard rumors
of.
For a time, I had thought it to have been
the reason for AWCY’s founding; after all
its nickname was derived from a particular
traditional art form.
SCP-173, The Sculpture, as those at the Foundation
call it.
I was able to insert myself into a group of
two other personnel; a researcher and security
officer.
The former was entering the container housing
SCP-173 to run tests, the latter protecting
her.
Naturally, I overheard them looking for a
third and offered my assistance, even if all
I had to do was watch The Sculpture intently.
I wasn’t even allowed to blink without getting
someone else to cover for me while I did.
I adored it.
The messy structure of concrete and rebar
defied all notions of what many believed art
should be; it wasn’t beautiful or pristine,
it dared to be ugly.
And yet, it demanded to be seen, to be looked
at and perceived, or else it would break my
neck and claim my life.
It was everything I’d hoped: pure art, personified.
It was as I neared the end of my first week
in Site-19 that I discovered my next anomalous
art piece, hidden away in a secure storage
locker.
SCP-010, the Collars of Control.
These were a collection of cast iron collars
that, according to their file, could be used
to control the actions and movements of a
person wearing one, via a remote control.
These collars fascinated me.
They were, to my interpretation, tools to
control yet simultaneously a rejection of
the very rules that control human beings.
Someone wearing an SCP-010 collar could potentially
have their entire bodily shape reconfigured
by the person wielding the remote.
That alone, the fact these objects could be
used to defy the physical laws that dictate
the forms we exist in, was a meta comment,
rejecting the laws of society in order for
free expression.
Expression only achieved by art; it all made
me appreciate AWCY’s dedication to anomalous
artworks.
Yet, I was still determined to be welcomed
into their collective.
My first week hiding within Site-19 concluded
with a visit to SCP-107.
Held on a pedestal in an otherwise empty room
was an empty, hollowed-out turtle shell.
Now, I, for one, don’t respect archaeologists.
Art historians are another matter; however,
I would rather focus on translating the human
experience into my art than waste mental energy
on events or objects from hundreds and thousands
of years ago.
But this turtle shell might be the exception.
Apparently, any liquid placed within the shell
will be absorbed, only to rain down from the
clouds above.
There’s something quite honest about SCP-107;
interpreted through the mind of an artist
such as myself, it appears to be a reminder
of the natural world’s cyclical process.
The liquid within it becomes rain, which falls
and feeds the plants.
The plant life in turn provides food and shelter
for animals, humans too, and so on.
On and on, the circle of life repeats, as
so embodied by the hollow shell of an ancient,
proud turtle.
I began my second week of subterfuge with
a scare, a close call that I may have been
discovered.
One of the Foundation doctor’s had complained
that his sink had been sliced in two, in spite
of my best efforts to cover my tracks.
It seemed that using his denture glue to repair
the damage SCP-063 had done didn’t quite
have the effect I had intended.
Nevertheless, the reaction by the Foundation
seemed to imply that that sort of thing happened
all the time.
An announcement was made reminding all researchers
not to toy with The World’s Best Tothbrush,
“despite how fun it was to slice things
up with”.
Although they requested the culprit come forward,
I decided to divert the Foundation’s suspicions
away from me, hinting to a security officer
I had seen Doctor Alto Clef leaving the private
bathroom where I had accidentally broken the
sink.
They seemed to believe he had been capable
of causing the damage.
Almost being discovered meant I had to reassess
my objective.
Over the following few days, I tried to sink
into life among the Foundation’s researchers,
playing the role of a helpful member of personnel
so as not to attract any further suspicions.
And so, I was mostly concerned with the general
day-to-day tending to anomalies.
Most of them I encountered during this time
were living creatures, which were of little
interest to me.
Although one, by the designation of SCP-049,
sported the rather aesthetically striking
appearance of a Plague Doctor, complete with
dark robes and a beaked mask.
At first, I thought him to be quite an amicable,
intelligent fellow.
That is, until I had a moment alone with him
to ask his opinions on art.
The Plague Doctor claimed it was ‘of little
importance’ when compared to curing ‘the
pestilence.
Naturally, I took that to be a personal insult,
requesting to the Research Head that I be
transferred away from an anomaly that was
obviously not as intelligent as I first thought.
Two and a half weeks had passed, and I had
still remained undetected by the Foundation.
However, I had been forced to reassess my
mission.
AWCY were hardly likely to accept me into
their group if I had nothing to show for my
efforts.
I needed either some materials I could use
to create an anomalous art piece or – preferably
– something I could claim as my own.
It wasn’t as if the upper echelons of AWCY
possessed their own detailed files on every
anomaly at Site-19.
They would have no idea if something I plucked
from containment was an existing SCP or a
Stathis Stern original piece.
So, I set about finding something that could
be my Magnum Opus, my breakthrough into the
anomalous art community – my key to the
fame, fortune, and artistic acclaim I so obviously
deserved.
You may call it plagiarism, using another
anomaly as my own piece, but nobody technically
owns the objects and entities at Site-19.
Even the Foundation themselves are more jailors,
and curators, than creators.
I, however, am a visionary – I just needed
something to prove it.
My search took me far and wide, all over the
width and breadth of Site-19.
By the time my first whole month had passed,
I had begun to walk its corridors and pass
by its containment chambers just like any
other researcher.
Although, not one who I interacted with had
any clue they were in the presence of the
man who would reshape the anomalous art world.
There was an SCP transferred from another
facility that I witnessed during that time.
According to the Foundation’s files, SCP-066
had previously been a ball of braided yarn
and ribbon, but had since become an amorphous
ball of meat with functioning eyes.
What struck me the most about SCP-066 was
the question it asked since transforming.
“Are you Eric?”
At first, I thought, I’m not Eric.
But the longer I pondered it, I began to wonder,
allowing my perception to be challenged.
That is what art does, after all.
Perhaps, much in the Marshal Mathers sense
that ‘We are all Stan’, all of us may
well be Eric too…
I can recall another incident encountering
some SCP-131s, creatures known as the Eye
Pods, when one almost tripped me up.
Their brightly-colored teardrop-shaped bodies
were certainly striking, a rather abstract,
modernist biomechanical design.
But it was their eyes that I found myself
ruminating on.
SCP-131 instances had a single, unblinking
eye, giving a constant gaze without faltering.
I likened it much to the uncritical, unthinking
eyes of certain audiences, who in the past
had started at my artwork and had nothing
interesting to say about it.
In other events, my attempts to avoid detection
may have proven a little detrimental.
Doctor Clef cornered me, a little perturbed
that I had implicated him in the ‘sink slicing’
incident.
He at one point he seemed to imply a desire
to inflict far worse damage with… a ukulele
of all things.
Although, I’m sure he was just joking.
At least, I hope so.
The whole interaction reminded me of the urgency
of my mission, I still needed my anomalous
masterpiece, and would need to have an escape
plan in place once I found it.
During my next stint of time hidden among
the ranks of the Foundation, I tried to broaden
my own interpretation of what AWCY would consider
to be ‘art’.
Nothing in their admittedly vaguely defined
rules stated my anomalous piece couldn’t
be created from a more modern medium.
Never mind paintings that can depict a person’s
death or a sculpture that moves whenever unobserved,
what about something like photography, I thought
to myself.
However, it was around this time that my hopes
for such a piece were seemingly answered,
in the form of SCP-105, or Iris Thompson as
she introduced herself.
Iris had a rather unique relationship with
the art of photography.
She possessed an ability to alter images taken
on a specific Polaroid Express camera from
1982.
In the hands of SCP-105, the photographs would
come to life, like slices of real-time frozen
one moment then moving the second she held
them.
She could even alter these images, reaching
into the Polaroid to move or retrieve objects.
It instilled an idea in me, perhaps taking
a polaroid of my chosen anomalous art, would
be enough.
That is, until I realized the photographs
were only interactable to Iris, and breaking
her out of containment was a waste of my skills
as an artist.
Partway into my third month hiding out in
Site-19, part of me began to wonder if the
Foundation’s security forces were as formidable
as I’d been led to believe.
It seemed I barely even needed to hide my
mission to join AWCY, or that I had spent
so much time in their facility undetected.
It was on my sixty-eighth day that I decided
to reflect on some of the potential anomalous
pieces I had encountered so far.
Frustratingly so, I was still yet to discover
any that would wipe the smug grins off the
AWCY members, only to replace them with looks
of awe.
Something in Site-19 would guarantee my spot
among the anomalous art collective, I was
certain of it.
I just had to find it.
A potential candidate presented itself, one
that might have even allowed me to get my
own back on AWCY for denying my entry for
so long.
I was shown SCP-3037, a miniature model that
depicted the city of Dubrovnik in Croatia.
I was watching it and pondering the meaning
behind this sculpture, thinking about why
it had been made specifically to look like
Dubrovnik, of all places.
Maybe, I pondered, it was meant to be a commentary
or condemnation of urbanization, given the
city’s walls keeping its residents contained,
confined, much like how we as humans have
become trapped by our urban settings, finding
comfort in being confined there.
However, it was while examining SCP-3037 that
I apparently suffered something of an incident.
From the moment I touched it, I spoke in only
Serbo-Croatian, believing myself to actually
be the city of Dubrovnik.
I awoke a short while later, and was informed
by another researcher that I had been administered
with an extremely high dose of amnestics to
negate the effects of SCP-3037.
Although later that night, I recalled having
a dream about some delicious Black Risotto
with squid ink sauce.
The Research heads ordered security officers
to gather everyone in the mess hall.
The Foundation was seemingly aware that they
had an imposter, a charlatan, in their midst
pretending to be a member of personnel.
I made sure my facial expression did not betray
that I was the one they sought.
Not one of these philistines could appreciate
my goal of infiltrating Site-19.
Not one had the slightest clue how revolutionary
my actions would be for the art world.
However, although staying vigilant, I became
increasingly aware time might not be on my
side much longer.
After overhearing a conversation about something
known as SCP-035, I began conducting my own
secretive research into what it was.
I discovered information on the so-called
‘Possessive Mask’ within the Foundation’s
archives.
Immediately, my heart skipped a beat, the
porcelain mask that shifted from an exaggerated
comedic grin to a wide frown; it would have
made for a perfect art piece to present to
AWCY.
Much to my annoyance, SCP-035 wasn’t housed
at Site-19, however.
Over the next few days, I petitioned to have
the Possessive Mask transferred to the facility
so I could claim it.
My greatest anomalous art piece stayed out
of reach though.
I was informed by senior research staff that
the mask posed a potential danger; anyone
nearby was compelled to wear it and would
thus be taken over by its influence.
Additionally, questions started to be raised
as to why I was requesting this transfer in
the first place.
I was starting to grow concerned that my cover
had been blown.
By now, it very much seemed that my time was
running out.
And although it shames me to admit, to say
I handled that notion with grace and professionality…
well, that would be a lie.
Suddenly, I found it: the perfect anomalous
art piece.
While rummaging around the Foundation’s
files, I located one about something known
as SCP-1379.
As I read more, I realized it would secure
my spot within AWCY and forever grant me the
recognition I deserved.
Even better: it was a painting!
Such a classical art medium, they’d never
be able to refuse me!
As I looked at it directly for the first time,
I knew I had found my masterpiece.
SCP-1379 depicted a clown and two children
on the canvas.
But the subject of the painting would hardly
matter to AWCY, they only cared that the artwork
was anomalous.
And SCP-1379 certainly was.
This painting would allow me to exact revenge
on the AWCY members who’d failed to recognize
my artistic genius for so long.
Anyone that made a critical remark on SCP-1379
– which those AWCY snobs were bound to do
when they saw it – would first experience
intense pain.
After twenty minutes of sharp, severe agony,
the sensations would subside.
But that’d only be the start of it.
Everyone at the AWCY that dared to criticize
my Magnum Opus, my SCP-1379, would rapidly
lose their ability to imagine.
Any of their creativity that had allowed them
to laud their artistic superiority over me
would cease to exist.
None of them would ever make anomalous art
again, and they’d surely be forced to finally
accept that I am, in fact, the greatest artist
of all time.
From the moment I saw it, I began to plan
my escape, with SCP-1379 in tow.
A hundred days have passed since I arrived
here, and when I leave, it will be with SCP-1379
and this journal.
I’ve not only chronicled how I infiltrated
the SCP Foundation, but also cataloged more
about anomalous art than anyone at AWCY ever
has.
Once I’ve lifted that painting from its
containment locker, my old friends at the
Insurgency have arranged for me to be extracted
from Site-19.
With SCP-1379, finally I’ll achieve my dream
of-
This journal – belonging to one Stathis
Sterns – has been seized by the SCP Foundation.
Sterns was discovered to have infiltrated
Site-19 after only a handful of days.
However, given that he posed little threat,
and never left the facility, security officers
were instructed to monitor him closely until
he attempted to escape.
Aware of intelligence regarding various SCPs
noted within his journal, the Foundation deemed
Stathis Sterns a security risk after one-hundred
days.
Subject was arrested attempting to escape
and is to be administered amnestics.
His journal will remain at Site-19 until further
notice.
Oh god, I’m back, I made it back and I’m
still alive.
That… thing, the Old Man, it had been tormenting
me for months, following me, trapping me God
knows where.
But I’m out now… and yet somehow that’s
just as bad.
Let me explain…
It all really started about a hundred days
ago, I didn’t start keeping a tally of the
days until a little after things started to
get strange.
But if I think back, the first sign happened
on a completely normal day.
I had been stocking up on supplies with my
eldest, Jimmy.
The superstore in town had a limit on how
much you could spend in a single transaction,
so we had to hit up a few different places
for canned food to store in the bunker.
When we got back, my wife Janey said she’d
noticed a stain upstairs.
Sure enough, she pointed it out to me; a slightly
discolored patch on the ceiling above our
bed.
There wasn’t much there at first, it just
looked like a little area of damp, but I promised
I’d have a look at it over the weekend.
No point wasting money on a handyman, I didn’t
think much of it.
I definitely didn’t think of it as anything
to worry about… but I was so, so wrong.
The very next day, I was outside, making a
full inventory of everything in the bunker.
We had everything, all kinds of practical
equipment for any manner of disaster.
Not just food and water, but ropes and tools,
tents and sleeping bags in case my family
and I ever needed to abandon the bunker and
sleep in the wild.
You see, my whole life I’d been sure that
something was coming, that out on the horizon,
the end of the world was waiting.
The way I saw it, if civilization was one
day going to completely collapse, then I needed
to prepare to make sure my family and I made
it through.
Maybe part of it was the fear too, but when
you’re scared of something, you make yourself
ready for it, right?
Anyway, it was while I was listing the food
rations and trying to figure out just how
many months we’d survive on them, when Janey
came in from the house.
“Jake, that stain on the ceiling’s getting
bigger!”
she declared, dragging me back indoors to
show me.
As far as I could see, it hadn’t changed
much since the day before.
The day after that though, that was a different
story.
Janey didn’t have to point it out, I could
clearly tell that something wasn’t right
about that mark on our ceiling.
It wasn’t just bigger, it was leaking.
But not just water, it didn’t seem like
it had come from a leaky pipe somewhere in
the house.
There was a dark, gooey substance, almost
like tar, that looked as if it had bled through
the surface of the ceiling from the floor
above.
Except, that was the weird thing: there was
no floor above, and our bedroom was on the
highest level of the house.
Apart from the attic, of course.
I climbed up on the bed to take a closer look
at the greasy patch that was now the size
of two dinner plates.
Wearing a thick pair of gloves, I reached
up to wipe away some of the muck.
Immediately, I could smell something burning;
the fingers of my glove had started to melt.
I ran into the bathroom, and pushed it off
my hand from the wrist.
By now, this black ooze had started to spread
much further across the ceiling, reaching
to just above our bed.
Janey told me she didn’t feel comfortable
sleeping under whatever that stuff was, after
it had eaten through my gloves.
I told her she didn’t need to worry, it
wasn’t dripping from the ceiling, and we’d
be fine as long as we just didn’t touch
it.
Even then, she still opted to sleep on the
couch.
That night, I had a really weird dream.
I was convinced that I’d woken up in the
middle of the night, restless and uneasy knowing
Janey wasn’t in the bed next to me.
That’s when I looked up at that slick patch
of darkness smeared across the ceiling.
But there was something else there too: a
face, a grotesque face staring down at me,
grinning a wide, lipless smile.
I’m sure it was a dream, it had to be, I’d
been putting off doing anything about the
stain, that’s why I dreamt about it, right?
Or maybe I was awake and it was just a trick
of the light…
“What do you mean you won’t call someone?”
Janey asked indignantly.
“I just don’t see the point!”
I argued.
We had gotten into something of a heated debate
over what to do about the goop on our ceiling.
I’d decided not to tell her about my nightmare,
but even then, she was determined that I get
a handyman or someone to come and take a look
at it.
“It’d be a waste of money,” I tried
to convince her.
“Why should we shell out money for someone
when I can just get some disinfectant and
clean it up myself?”
“Because you don’t know what it is, even
if you could just wipe it off, it might come
back!” she yelled.
“You’d rather try to sort it out quickly
so you can get back to working on your bunker!”
“That’s to keep us safe!”
I retorted.
“Look, Jake.
I’ve humored it for long enough, but you
spend more time out there than looking after
your own house,” Janey sighed.
I refused, I knew it was the stubborn, petty
thing to do, but I had taken Janey’s comments
about my bunker to heart.
She’d never minded before, always understood
that I was only doing it for us.
I think she saw the good place it came from
first, and that meant more than the actual
work I’d done stockpiling supplies and making
sure we’d have working plumbing after the
collapse.
Later that day, I caught both Jimmy and Jake
Jr were lingering at the bedroom door, staring
up at the thick, dark sludge on the ceiling.
The pair of them were both keeping themselves
behind the doorframe or gripping the door
itself like a shield.
My boys were scared of it, it was clear as
day.
“Dad, is the house sick?”
Jake Jr asked.
“Houses don’t get sick,” his older brother
interjected.
“It’s haunted…
there’s a monster in the attic, right Dad?”
“No monsters and the house isn’t sick,”
I replied, forcing a smile to my sons.
“I’ll take care of it.”
About a week after the stain had first appeared,
it was time for the monthly drill.
Every four weeks, I’d gather my family and
we’d do a little practice just in case the
worst should happen.
At the sound of an air horn, we’d all have
to grab the bug out bags I’d prepared for
everyone, and run out to the bunker in under
five minutes.
The boys were always eager, it helped that
they were both young enough that we could
treat it like a game.
Janey, though, she didn’t want to get involved
in this drill.
She stayed indoors, trying to play it off
to the kids as if she was just busy.
But the side glance she shot at me said different,
and it was hard to avoid the guilt that came
with it.
That, coupled with seeing the boy’s reaction
to it, convinced me that it would just be
easier to have someone come take a look at
the slimy patch above the bed.
I’d needed to go to town the next day, another
supply run, so I picked up the number of a
repair guy while I was out, even called him
on the way home, thinking that would make
it up to Janey.
But as I pulled up to the driveway, I could
hear screaming coming from the house.
I raced indoors and that’s when I saw my
wife, standing between our two boys and…
it.
It was like a desiccated corpse, an Old Man
with viscous black grease leaking out of his
decaying body.
The same substance that had pooled on our
bedroom ceiling… and was now covering Janey.
The Old Man had her arm gripped in his body
hand, the same fluid coating her skin and
burning her.
She was shrieking in pain, tears running down
her face as the boys cowered behind her.
I froze, I had no idea what to do… so I
ran.
I had acted out of panic, and spent the next
week regretting it deeper than any mistake
I’d ever made.
I’d left my bugout bag in the house and
just blindly sprinted straight for the bunker
while the screams of my wife and kids filled
the house.
In the days that followed, everything fell
quiet, but even then, I barely slept.
Through a porthole in the heavy metal door,
I watched the rear of my home.
Occasionally I’d catch sight of movement
inside, some tiny bit of motion, usually at
night.
I kept hoping it would be Janey, or one of
the boys, having found a place to hide and
then making their way out the back door to
me.
But every time, it was only ever him.
The Old Man slunk through my family’s home,
staring out at me with lidless eyes, his jaw
locked in a twisted grin like he was enjoying
tormenting me.
A sharp knock on the bunker door woke me up
from the short, restless sleep.
I sat bolt upright, immediately expecting
that thing to be on the other side.
It was the handyman I’d called a few days
earlier – it seemed like such a trivial
matter now.
“There was no answer at the front,” he
explained to me.
“Hope you don’t mind me coming around
the back, your side gate was open.”
Barely paying him any mind, I dashed towards
the house.
There was no sign of the Old Man, but I couldn’t
find Janey’s body, or the two boys’ anywhere.
I went to grab my bugout bag, only to run
into the handyman in the hallway.
Before I could urge him to run, to leave the
house, the Old Man’s face appeared, pushing
through another slick, oily black puddle in
the wall, grabbing the other man and dragging
him in as I bolted for the door.
Heading for the woods was my safest option
– no, my only option.
If I went to the police, there was no way
they’d believe such an outlandish story.
They’d probably suspect me of murdering
my family, or think I was crazy if I told
them a zombie had attacked my home.
That got me thinking, what the hell was that
Old Man?
He couldn’t have been a zombie, for a start
there was only one and he wasn’t turning
people.
But there was something off about his actions,
almost like they weren’t mindless shuffling
and attacks.
There was an intent behind them.
He was patient.
Camping out in the woods brought me no joy,
even with all the supplies in my bag.
Whenever I tried to sleep, I’d just lay
awake for hours, thinking of my family…
and the grotesque face of the Old Man.
Every sound in the night – the wind rustling
leaves, animals cracking sticks underfoot
– in my mind, everything I heard was him
getting closer and closer.
And pretty soon he did.
I started keeping watch during the nights,
and I’d catch sight of a silhouetted figure
in the darkness.
Every few days, he would reappear.
He’d never get close enough to attack me,
just enough to force me to pack up camp again
and relocate.
Until one night, I could hear the sound of
gurgled breathing outside my tent.
I reached for my flashlight, casting its light
over the walking corpse that stood outside.
It recoiled from the bright light, but as
its decaying face illuminated, I ran, leaving
my campsite and bag where they were.
I didn’t care, I just sprinted through the
woods, branches scratching at me like the
decrepit bony fingers of the Old Man clawing
at my skin.
I could hear water running, barely seeing
the stream in my flashlight before my foot
sank into it.
Wading through, I crawled out on the opposite
bank, cold, wet, and still trying to get away.
The days that followed were hard, with no
supplies I had to survive on what little I
had left in my pockets.
My best bet, I thought, was to keep hiking,
keep putting distance between myself and him.
And for a while, it was working… or I thought
it was.
It wasn’t until I came across tracks, not
like animal tracks, not even an ordinary human’s
footprints.
They were thick with that black, burning tar,
melting into the forest ground in the shape
of the Old Man’s foot.
I’d gone around in a circle.
The whole time I thought I was getting away
from him, I had just been going around and
around.
When I stumbled upon what was still left of
my campsite, I should have been overjoyed,
but instead, my heart dropped through to the
bottom of my stomach.
I shouldn’t have stopped there, that was
what he wanted.
But I was hungry, exhausted, and just needed
to sleep.
That was when he got me, I woke up to the
stench of some burning substance, only to
find something locked tightly around my ankle;
one of the Old Man’s hands.
Another of his greasy gateways had opened
on a nearby tree, and he was pulling me inside.
The pain was what hit me first, before I could
even get a good look at where I was or what
was around me.
Instead, all I felt was the most excruciating
agony I’d ever experienced.
Looking down, I saw why.
The Old Man had two of his bony, clawed fingers
hooked into my ankle.
Not just holding me by it, his fingers were
going through and it hurt.
The black sludge was still dripping from him
and onto me.
The more of it passed through my clothes,
touched my skin, and mixed with my blood,
the more I felt it burning.
Digging in the fingers of his other hand,
the Old Man pulled apart the bones in my lower
leg like the wishbone of a turkey, only with
a much louder and far more painful snap.
The shock left me unconscious again, lost
and now with half of my leg forcibly ripped
away.
I had no idea where I was, and for some strange
reason the Old Man had left me to wander around
freely.
Although I’d soon find out why.
It hurt just to move, but I wrapped my leg
up and crawled my way around the vast labyrinth.
Even if I still had my bag, which had a compass
in it, it still would have been impossible
to navigate.
I tried to take shelter under my jacket, hiding
and setting up as much of a camp as I could.
Every time I thought I was safe, a greasy
black puddle would begin to form on the nearest
wall, and that same decaying face with the
lipless grin came through it.
But that was why he let me wander, just so
he could make sure I never slept; my suffering
was a game to him.
The longer I spent there, the more tired I
became.
Through lack of sleep, searing pain of my
forcibly amputated leg, and the fear of trying
to keep away from the Old Man, I started to
get low.
I had no way of escaping.
Even if I tried stepping through one of those
black puddles, it would just corrode me.
But I started to think, maybe that would’ve
been better.
Getting home meant having to live without
Janey.
She would still be gone, Jimmy and Jake Jr
weren’t going to be waiting for me if I
somehow managed to make it back.
I had been keeping a tally of the days since
I’d left, adding on the week when the stain
first appeared.
It had been ninety days.
I couldn’t take anymore.
I just wanted it over.
I didn’t see the point to continuing this
torture, I wanted to leave and I wanted my
family back.
The only way to get both was to let the Old
Man get me.
But he must’ve known I was looking for him,
every time I yelled out into the confusing
maze I was stuck in, I never got an answer.
He wouldn’t come and find me.
I couldn’t tell if he knew how badly I was
suffering stuck here and just wanted to prolong
that, or if he’d gotten bored of me.
Eventually, after over another week without
rest, I tried to sleep again.
And that was when he came for me.
Only I didn’t bother to run this time, as
I saw the corpse-like creature shambling towards
me, black grease covering its body.
I closed my eyes and waited for it to happen.
When I came back to consciousness, my vision
was filled with nothing but bright, white
light.
I thought that maybe this was it, that the
Old Man had caught me and decided to put an
end to the chasing and torture.
For a brief few seconds, I was certain that
I was dead.
What else are you supposed to think when you
wake up squinting at a blinding light?
But I wasn’t dead and hadn’t been delivered
to the afterlife.
And I wasn’t still in that horrible labyrinth,
that nightmarish place I had just been for
over a month.
Feeling the cold, hard ground, something in
the pit of my stomach told me I was back in
the real world.
Still unable to see properly, I raised a hand
to block out some of the glare, the sounds
of heavy boots clomping towards me.
Two pairs of gloved hands reached out and
grabbed my arms, dragging me out of the path
of the intense light.
As they did, I started blinking away the spots
in my vision, and that’s when I saw masses
of machinery and the creature, the Old Man
caught in the beams of three white spotlights.
I looked up at the people who had saved me,
a pair of figures in tactical gear, their
uniforms bearing the insignia of something
called the ‘SCP Foundation’.
As grateful as I was to this Foundation for
pulling me out of that nightmare, and as glad
as I was to still be alive, I couldn’t help
but feel more and more uneasy as they debriefed
me.
Maybe it was just how interested they seemed
in my encounter with the Old Man – or SCP-106,
as they called it – as I described what
had happened in a lengthy debrief.
Or it might have been how quick they were
to shrug off what the Old Man had done to
my family.
Whatever it was, I didn’t trust them, even
though they seemed to believe my story.
Recalling it all made me think of Janey and
my two boys again.
I used to be so afraid of the world ending,
spent all that time and money making sure
I was ready for when the end finally hit.
But it had snuck up on me, it didn’t matter
that the Earth was still turning, my world
was gone.
And, I figured, that must have been why the
Old Man kept me alive.
It could’ve easily killed me if it really
wanted to, but it let me live on, not just
so it could torture me, but so I’d be alive
to know my family were gone.
It wasn’t long after I realized this that
the Foundation offered me something, medicine
they said would help me forget about it all.
If I didn’t take it, I’d at least get
to remember what I used to have, but also
live with the pain of not having it anymore.
That was the Old Man’s real torture... so
I had to.
As I washed down the pill with a swig of water,
I thought back to Janey and my sons with tears
in my eyes, wishing them goodbye before they
were really gone forever.
It’s hard to believe it’s been over three
whole months since those monsters came to
town.
If only I had known back then what they were
really doing here, maybe I could have stopped
it.
I don’t know how, so much of this is beyond
me.
What could I have done?
Even if I had known about it, could I have
stopped what happened to all those people…
Sickness, Sarkicism, the SCP Foundation.
It’s all still such a blur, but for a while,
I can still remember how I Spent 100 Days
Infiltrating a Sarkic Cult.
It all began on a pretty ordinary day.
I live in a small lumber town, most of the
area is cut off from major cities, connected
only by miles and miles of winding road through
the forest.
It’s a quiet rural place, and a low-tech
way of life.
Our main business has been timber, generations
of tree cutters; even in the modern age, we
keep that going.
Although my home had always been off the beaten
track, we often had our fair share of visitors.
Hikers and wanderers would sometimes stumble
upon the town quite by accident, yet be so
enthralled by all the natural beauty on offer
that they’d just have to spend a night at
the only hotel in town, the ‘Woodsman’s
Lodge’, run by my friend Andreas.
That’s what we thought they were at first.
Just visitors.
That’s why we welcomed them when they arrived.
Because not one of us had any idea who these
really were… what they really were.
We could never have known that they had chosen
our town specifically.
They had come here on purpose.
Many of the warier among our town thought
these newcomers were strange.
They were a group of five, very obviously
monied, but less obvious was their reasons
for coming here.
When friendly townsfolk tried to drum up a
conversation with any of them, they all seemed
to report the same thing.
That these strangers were aloof, and each
one gave a dramatically different answer as
to why they had come to our quite little logging
community.
One said their group were just sightseeing,
another said they had gotten lost.
Someone else from their group told a local
man they were here on a mission from someone
called Karcist Varis, and was rumored to have
been quickly silenced by another in the visitors’
party.
But the one thing they all seemingly agreed
on was that they wouldn’t be any trouble.
They insisted on that, in fact, and said the
five of them were just looking for somewhere
to sleep.
Bed and board in exchange for cash.
And so, someone pointed them in the direction
of Andreas’ hotel.
I was often there myself, not as a guest,
but helping my friend maintain the place.
He’d inherited the hotel from his family,
but it was always in need of repair.
Luckily, my background was in carpentry, and
I was more than happy to help old Andreas
out.
It wasn’t one of your fancy, furnished hotels,
the kind you’d find in a big city, all slick
and sleek and owned by a big chain.
It was homely, a more bed-and-breakfast type
of place.
It was, anyway.
Whenever I was working over at the Woodsman’s,
I’d observe the strange group of visitors
from a distance.
They didn’t seem to me like average tourists
or sightseers.
To me, they looked wealthy, very wealthy.
It wasn’t hard to picture any one of them
as a politician or a businessman, the way
they dressed and carried themselves made it
pretty clear they were people of influence.
Of course, that begged the question: what
on Earth were people like that doing in a
town like this?
I first got to speak with one of them after
a few days.
The five newcomers were down a man, and didn’t
seem at all happy about that.
The remaining four were grumpy, looking angered
and agitated.
I wondered if maybe their fifth compatriot
had left in the night, but when I asked around
town, apparently, nobody had seen him.
“Unless he’s crazy and decided to hike
through the woods on his own in the middle
of the night,” one of my friends scoffed,
after telling me that no one had even heard
any cars leaving the night before.
I decided to ask one of the visitors when
he passed me in the hallway of the Woodsman’s
Lodge, trying to broach the topic as tactfully
as I could.
“Sorry to see you’re down a man,” I
told him.
He stopped in his tracks, like I’d just
caught him doing something he shouldn’t
be.
“Yes, yes,” he replied, not turning around
to face me.
“It’s a terrible shame.
A terrible shame indeed.
But he had to leave us.
It was for his own good.
He knew that.
We all do.”
Following that odd encounter, things got all
the stranger the following day.
I arrived at the Woodsman’s again, expecting
to start another day of work.
I’d gotten a call from Andreas earlier that
morning; he was complaining about some kind
of squelching noise coming from the basement
under the hotel, that had only started last
night.
I told him I wasn’t a plumber, but that
I’d take a look.
So, imagine my surprise when I saw Andreas
loading most of his worldly possessions up
into a truck outside the front of his hotel.
He excitedly explained to me that he’d been
bought out, that the remaining four newcomers
had offered to buy the Woodsman’s on the
spot.
“But that’s your family’s hotel, Andreas!”
I reminded him, as if it wasn’t already
too late.
“I was never going to be able to keep it
afloat forever,” he shrugged.
“When they told me how much they were willing
to pay, I couldn’t refuse.
You would have done the same, Ingvar.
I have never been offered so much money!”
This all made it very clear: these guests
were here to stay.
It had taken less than a week for me to grow
suspicious of these people.
It wasn’t in my nature to pry, but so much
about them just didn’t make any sense.
They were clearly rich enough to buy Andreas’
hotel like it was nothing, just an ordinary
everyday purchase like buying a loaf of bread.
But they were far too insular to seemingly
want to run a hotel for our friendly logging
town.
It left me scratching my head over the whole
thing, making the question of what they were
really up to stick out like an unignorable
splinter.
Were these just careless rich folk with more
money than sense?
Had they somehow grown disillusioned with
their wealthy affluent lifestyles and were
now using this hotel to learn how to connect
with people on a more fulfilling personal
level?
Or did they have a different agenda, something
else that they were trying to hide?
It turns out, they did…
I decided to formally introduce myself to
the new owners of the Woodsman’s.
After all, I knew the place well; it always
needed something repairing.
Plus, if I could keep my little side job of
working there as a handyman going, then maybe
I could find out exactly what they were doing.
I was greeted by the man of their group I’d
spoken to briefly the other day, looking at
me with a scowl as I stood in the doorway.
“Hello, sir!”
I greeted warmly, met with silence.
“We, uh, we met the other day?”
“What do you want?”
“Oh, well,” I continued, disarmed by the
bluntness.
“I understand your group just bought this
place.
I had a gentlemen’s agreement with the last
owner.
I’d help him out, fix things that need fixing.
I just thought I should offer the same service
to you if you’d be interested.
Might help get this hotel up and running nice
and quick for you, so you can start making
a return on your investment.”
With that, the door was unceremoniously slammed
in my face.
At first, it certainly seemed like my options
for uncovering more about this strange group
were all but depleted.
Or at least, doing so through any legitimate
means.
But just as I was reaching a desperate point
where I was considering donning a balaclava
and breaking into the hotel in the dead of
night, opportunity remerged from behind that
closed door.
“We were sorry to turn you away yesterday,”
one of the other visitors apologized somewhat
insincerely.
“But we would be delighted to take you up
on your offer.
Provided you accept a few… conditions.”
“Conditions?”
I echoed.
“What would these be?”
“We would need you to start on repairs immediately,
we want to open up the hotel’s doors to
guests in the next few days as a matter of
urgency,” he explained.
“But you will need to be discreet.
Privacy is very important to us, so we hope
to maintain that for our guests.”
It all seemed like a lot of hoops to jump
through, certainly more than Andreas had given
me when he used to run the Woodsman’s.
But it felt like the right call, if it at
least got me closer to answers.
In hindsight, I should’ve turned them down…
Over the course of the next week, things seemed
to run relatively normally.
I’d be given a checklist of things to fix
around the hotel, and for the most part, just
focused purely on the tasks at hand.
But whenever the strange new owners were near,
I’d try to subtly listen in on their conversations.
They seemed to mostly talk about running the
hotel though, like they knew I was around.
A few tourists started showing up, in fact,
it seemed to get much busier than usual very
quickly.
I asked one of the odd owners about it, and
he just brushed it off as the result of their
group marketing the Woodsman’s Lodge more
widely on the Internet.
I didn’t see much of the hotel’s guests,
staying out of their way as I had been instructed
to.
But it did strike me as odd how few of them
seemed to leave.
Some I spotted around town, usually those
traveling as a couple or in a larger group.
Any that were staying alone though, they didn’t
seem to venture beyond the Woodsman’s.
None of them checked out either, but their
rooms would be empty, and often needed repairs
– mainly scratch marks on the wooden floorboards.
Two and a half weeks after the weird group
had arrived and bought up my friend’s hotel,
I got a call from someone I knew who lived
next door to the Woodsman’s.
“The hotel, someone was screaming!”
she said frantically over the line.
“Get here quick, they might need you!”
I checked the time; it was the dead of night,
so late that it was almost the start of the
next day.
Racing quickly over to the hotel, I was greeted
by one of the owners.
He had rushed to the door, wide awake like
he hadn’t even been sleeping.
When I told him there were reports of blood-curdling
screams, he reprimanded me.
“You were told, our guests’ privacy must
be maintained!” he scolded.
“If you must know, one of the hikers staying
with us tripped over and had a nasty fall.
He landed downstairs, in the basement, and
he’s in a lot of pain, not to be moved.
We’ve called for an ambulance.”
I wanted to take what he had said at face
value, but the fact he wouldn’t let me in
to see the injured man felt suspicious.
I spent the night with the person who lived
next door to the hotel, watching the Woodsman’s
Lodge for any sign of an ambulance.
It never arrived.
That was when I remembered: he had said the
guest fell into the basement.
The same basement Andreas had heard a strange
squelching coming from.
And not once had these new owners asked me
to take a look down there…
Already I was even further suspicious of the
new owners now.
I had no idea what they were up to, the wild
theories in my head ranged from them being
a group of sadistic serial killers using the
hotel to lure victims, or a shadowy government
black ops team up to something nefarious.
Enough was enough, I needed answers.
I couldn’t wait for an opportunity, I had
to create one.
While as few people were in the hotel as possible,
I snuck into the main office.
Not to steal anything or even peek just yet,
but to break the legs off a desk; if they
asked me to fix it, then I would be able to
spend longer in the office with no supervision.
Sure enough, they soon asked me I’d be able
to fix the desk, and that was my in.
I started rummaging through the filing cabinets,
rifling through whatever I could find.
Old expenses reports, legal documents left
behind by Andreas, but there was nothing that
could give me any inkling as to what was actually
going on.
Until there was…
You see, as much as it came as a surprise
to no one more than me, I wasn’t the only
one looking into this strange group…
One of the guests entered the office and quickly
realized what he was doing.
At first, he seemed to imply that I was somehow
in league with the new owners.
But I was able to talk him around, telling
him I just wanted to try to get to the bottom
of what they were up to.
That was when he revealed to me who he was.
“Agent Clericson,” he introduced himself.
“I’m here on behalf of the SCP Foundation.”
After he brought me up to speed on what the
hell that all meant, we arranged to reconvene
somewhere they wouldn’t overhear us.
Meeting up at the lumber mill, he explained
that these four strangers were a cult, a subsect
of a strange religion I had never heard of
called Sarkicism.
But after Agent Clericson described their
practices, I wouldn’t soon forget; ritualistic
sacrifices, cannibalism, and even far, far
worse than that…
it made me feel sick just hearing about it.
Over the next few days, Clericson agreed to
let me help in his investigation, offering
me the chance to help the Foundation and make
it so that nobody in my remote little logging
town would ever have to suffer the memory
of what the Sarkic cult were up to.
Little did I realize he also meant me.
I did my best to spy on the death and disease
worshipping cultists without drawing too much
suspicion and reported my findings back to
the Foundation agent.
But it quickly became clear that he was unimpressed
with my current method of just eavesdropping,
so instead, he suggested a more direct approach.
Clericson gave me a book on the Sarkic religion,
telling me to memorize as much as I could
and then approach the cultists as if I shared
in their twisted beliefs.
Even reading the teachings of Grand Karcist
Ion was enough to make my stomach turn.
All the grotesque things that the founder
of this cult’s beliefs preached in order
to achieve something akin to godhood… it
was horrific.
What was much more horrific, though, was that
our plan went awry.
I asked to speak alone with one of the cultists,
and instantly started explaining that I had
observed them for a time and come to realize
that we were one and the same.
In a state of panic, I regurgitated anything
I could still remember from reading about
Sarkicism, their goal to achieve apotheosis
through will, the consumption of gods, and…
sacrifice.
But I must have said something wrong; one
of them snuck up behind me and knocked me
unconscious.
I woke up in a daze, a splitting headache
running through my skull.
I was in a cage, in a part of the hotel I
hadn’t seen before.
It was dark, absent of natural light.
There were others too, I recognized one or
two of the hotel’s single guests, also trapped
in cages.
Agent Clericson was nowhere to be found.
The Sarkic cultists spent the next day asking
me how I had found them.
I told them the truth, and answered their
questions the only way I knew how, but I couldn’t
make them believe me.
“Liar!” one spat.
“You did your homework, I’ll admit.
But the Foundation is known for working in
broad strokes, missing out on the finer details.”
“We’re Neo-Sarkites,” another explained.
“You were spouting the teachings of the
Proto-Sarkic religion.
We believe the only way of becoming a god,
achieving the apotheosis, is through sheer
will.”
“And in terms of sacrifice,” one of the
other cultists chimed in.
“We’ll sacrifice many in service of us
few.
But you’ll soon come to witness more of
that.”
They kept me in the cage for days, without
food and barely any water.
I felt so drained of energy before long, and
I soon realized why no one had heard the captive
guests calling out for help.
They were so weak that they could barely gather
enough strength to shout, and those that did,
their voices were too weak to reach anyone
above the basement.
The cultists came and went all throughout
the day, alternating between running the Woodsman’s
Lodge and coming down into the dark, cramped
and disgusting room below.
The stench was foul, yet not one of the Sarkic
cultists seemed to mind.
They would just talk endlessly about the ‘new
age of Flesh’, before dragging their next
victim out of their cage at night and taking
them into a back room.
By this point, all the remaining hotel guests
that had been caged up with me were gone.
I could never fully see what went on in the
other room, but I certainly heard a lot.
There were muffled screams, followed by chanting
in a language I didn’t understand.
Then came the noise of something slithering,
all the while the cultists – who had gathered
in the room with their captive victim – kept
reciting their incantations.
I had no idea what was going on in there,
but the hotel guests never remerged, just
the Sarkites.
I had read enough about their rituals to get
a pretty good idea…
I had lost track of how long I’d been held
prisoner when Agent Clericson appeared in
the basement.
The cultists’ backs had been turned just
long enough for him to slip downstairs undetected.
For a moment, I thought I was saved, only
for my heart to sink when he told me he couldn’t
get me out.
I pleaded with him, but he insisted that he
needed to know exactly what was going on down
here.
As he left me on my own, I cursed him under
my breath.
Before much longer, the cultists decided it
was my turn.
They dragged me out of my cage and into the
back room, strapping me to a chair.
I had no strength left to fight back, but
I had plenty of fear.
There were more cages back here, it was an
old storeroom that they were now keeping…
nightmares in.
The things in the cages were disgusting abominations,
masses of bloody, gooey flesh… flesh that
had once been human.
I realized these were the hotel guests, the
ones who traveled alone, who never checked
out… whose fingernails had left scratches
on the floorboards as they were dragged out
of their rooms by the cultists.
Using a cattle prod, one of the Sarkites started
directing a creature towards me.
The horrible mutant was getting closer, an
appendage resembling an arm reaching out at
me.
It was going to turn me into one of them,
and I couldn’t stop it.
Scared for my life, I mustered the little
energy I had left to try and pull away from
the sickening creature, but just as it was
about to make contact…
someone kicked down the door.
Agent Clericson had returned with reinforcements,
members of a Mobile Task Force that promptly
arrested the Sarkic cultists and sealed the
room containing the monsters for the time
being.
He sat down next to me and explained what
had gone on, but I was barely awake enough
to keep up with all the details.
Something about “SCP-610 instances” and
“rare to see them this far out of Siberia”.
But he promised that the SCP Foundation would
be ordering the creatures to be incinerated
soon.
The Woodsman’s lodge would have to be burned
down as part of the cover story.
As for me, I just want to forget the whole
ordeal.
The Sarkic cult, all the people they turned
into monsters, the horrifying things they
do, the SCP-610s.
All of it, I want it all gone.
Luckily, Agent Clericson has given me something
he says will help with that.
He called it an amnestic…
What on earth is going on!?
One minute, I was just doing my job, protecting
the President of the United States from any
potential attacks.
The next thing I knew, thousands of people
were dead, the world was thrown into chaos,
and this so-called “SCP Foundation” had
declared war on the human race!?
Okay, okay, let’s get back to Day 1 before
things get too confusing.
Day 1.
I’m a member of the President’s secret
service, so it’s my job to keep POTUS safe
from all manner of potential dangers.
My son, Thomas, was in the care of my ex-wife
across the state when everything went south.
It started on the white house lawn, where
the president was giving a speech about his
plans to shrink the deficit.
That’s when he appeared.
A stranger slipped into the press junket.
He was dressed like a British butler.
It was almost comical.
Myself and the other agents immediately flagged
him as a potential threat and moved in to
intercept him.
That’s when things went nuts.
This Butler was one of the greatest fighters
I’ve ever seen - He effortlessly disarmed
the intercepting agents, and while we desperately
tried to wrestle the president off the stage,
the Butler stole one of my fellow agent’s
pistols, and blew off the president’s head
with one perfectly-aimed shot.
Of course, we returned fire, mowing the Butler
down in a hail of bullets.
But it was already too late.
People were screaming and running.
I could see, out in the city beyond, there
were explosions.
Smoke rising.
A cacophony of screams.
In an instant, everything had changed.
We all hunkered down in the White House to
protect the Vice President.
That’s when, upon turning on the news, we
saw The Message.
It’d been sent to every company, every station.
It read:
The following is a message composed via consensus
of the O5 Council.
For those who are not currently aware of our
existence, we represent the organization known
as the SCP Foundation.
Our previous mission centered around the containment
and study of anomalous objects, entities,
and other assorted phenomena.
This mission was the focus of our organization
for more than one hundred years.
Due to circumstances outside of our control,
this directive has now changed.
Our new mission will be the extermination
of the human race.
There will be no further communication.
Day 2.
Of course, I tried to get through to my ex-wife
and check that she and Thomas were okay, but
by that time, communication had already broken
down.
Strangely, the internet and major TV news
channels remained in operation, allowing them
to spew a constant barrage of the horrors
going on outside.
All over the world, hideous monsters and malicious
creatures had flooded the streets, killing
human beings en masse.
I don’t understand, is the SCP Foundation
behind all this?
I hadn’t even heard of them until yesterday,
and now, they were apparently releasing living
nightmares everywhere, apparently with the
intent of wiping out the human race.
All I could do was stay in place, hope my
family was staying safe, and do what I can
to protect the Vice President.
Day 3.
The Vice President is dead.
The same could be said for the rest of my
team.
Some terrifying, zombie-like man somehow breached
our security perimeter and melted down the
president and six secret service agents into
a thick, black sludge.
Obviously, not an ideal situation.
At that point, the chain of command collapsed
entirely and we decided to make a run for
it.
Bullets didn’t seem to work on that rotting
old freak, and I’m not the kind of idiot
who sees the point in expending a few extra
magazines on a lost cause.
But by the time I was outside, it was already
nightfall, and the horrors were just beginning…
Day 4.
It’s hell on earth out here.
I was wandering the streets of DC, trying
my best to remain scarce despite the chaos
unfolding all around me.
There were these creatures - abominations
of human flesh, twisted into unimaginably
unnatural configurations - roaming around,
attacking any humans they saw.
And anyone they touched started to transform
into more of them.
I decided to sleep in the back room of a ransacked
post office that night.
I didn’t want to move in the dark with these
things around.
One touch, and I’d be dead.
No thank you.
Day 5.
Why the hell did they do this to us!?
These monsters at the SCP Foundation, flooding
the world with abominations intent on ending
human life.
One of those flesh monsters almost killed
me today.
I was trying to sneak down a back alley when
I heard the chittering of bony legs following
me.
I turned and saw it, reaching out towards
me with fleshy tendrils.
I raised my handgun and fired several times,
to no effect.
I was preparing for death, or worse, when
some huge, metal vehicle I couldn’t recognize
pulled into the alley.
Men spilled out of it - Well, they weren’t
just men, they were cyborgs, in heavy, technologically-advanced
armor and weapons straight out of Star Wars.
They burned the creature to death with a volley
of concentrated heat beams.
I thanked my rescuers profusely and asked
them their names.
They simply told me:
“We’re devotees of the Broken God.
Stay safe out there, fellow traveler.
Mekhane be with you.”
Day 6.
I wasn’t just surviving for my own sake,
you need to understand that.
I wanted to get back to my ex-wife and son
as quickly as possible, knowing all the horrors
that the SCP Foundation had unleashed onto
the world for no logical reason.
As morbid as it sounds, even if we all died,
I’d rather we die together than apart.
But every day, I developed a new reason to
know this journey wouldn’t be easy.
While trying to escape from one of DC’s
more densely-packed urban areas, I encountered
a horrific monster.
It looked like a giant, mutant crocodile the
size of a bus, vicious as hell, and it could
talk.
When it clapped its eyes on me, it growled
“Disgusting…” and started running towards
me.
But the actual physical structure of DC saved
my ass this time.
You see, the streets of DC are designed to
give in and collapse if ever huge military
vehicles roll over them, in order to prevent
the capital from being invaded by a military
force.
The reptile clearly didn’t know this, cause
it seemed awful confused when the ground gave
out underneath it, and I was able to run to
safety while it tried to scramble up the walls.
Day 7.
A week into this hellish new world, and against
all odds, I’m still alive.
Though it’s not for lack of trying from
the gaggle of killer freaks the monsters at
the SCP Foundation have unleashed to terrorize
the streets.
Today, I saw something terrifying.
A man was lured into a dark corner by the
voice of a young child, claiming to be his
daughter.
He approached the dark with tears in his eyes
when a pack of monsters jumped out and began
devouring him alive.
Their long, sharp fangs and raw red hides
are going to linger in my dreams forever.
You can’t trust voices anymore.
You can’t trust them.
Day 8.
I’m almost at the edge of the city, but
the nightmares continue.
I was able to narrowly dodge a group of men
walking in perfect step, like one of those
flash mobs that always used to pop up.
In the middle of them, there was a woman with
what looked like some kind of strange skin
condition.
They didn’t seem all that aggressive until
they came upon a pair of women also trying
to make their way out of the city.
The men in the trancelike state charged at
them, holding the women in place and seeming
to strangle them while the woman with the
skin condition just laughed.
I would have charged in there to help, but
there were maybe twenty of the hypnotized
men in the group, and with one magazine of
handgun ammo left, even with perfect aim I
couldn’t drop them all.
But the guilt of leaving those women to die
will stay with me forever.
Over the next nine days, I encountered zombies.
I kid you not, genuine, honest-to-god zombies,
the Walking God Damn Dead, infesting a road
on the edge of town.
There was a huge crowd of them, gurgling and
growling, skin looking green and rotten.
I’ve seen so many zombie movies, but seeing
the genuine article in person was still utterly
revolting.
When they spotted me and started running towards
me, I instinctively pulled out my weapon and
fired several times.
I scored a couple of respectable headshots,
but they just kept coming.
The only thing I could do was run into a nearby
gas station and lock the door behind me.
For a second there, I thought I was doomed
until I suddenly developed the wherewithal
to check behind the cash register - Where,
to my immense luck, the clerk had apparently
left a pump-action shotgun with several shells.
With the extra firepower, I snuck out of the
back of the gas station, approached the zombie
horde from behind, and executed them with
a series of well-chosen shots.
I managed to steal and refuel a car to get
out of town.
On the way out, just to add to the surreality
of this whole situation, I saw a witch in
a ditch.
Sounds like I just made it up for the rhyme,
but no, there was a genuine witch hiding in
the grass, chewing on a dead body.
That was the moment that I knew, on some level,
that things would never be normal again.
The best I could hope for was survival.
The 21 days after that were incredibly eventful,
to say the least.
Thank god I had the foraged shotgun with me,
or I would have been a goner, because almost
as soon as I left town, that huge, monstrous
lizard appeared again, carrying a dead deer
in its mouth.
Had it followed me, or was it just a coincidence
that I ran into it again?
Hell, maybe there was more than one of those
horrible dinosaurs out there.
But the second it noticed me driving by, it
immediately began to chase me.
I put the pedal to the metal and hoped beyond
hope that this monster wouldn’t catch up
with me, but I kept seeing it get bigger and
bigger in my rear-view mirror.
That creature was impossibly fast for its
size, and believe me when I saw it was getting
close, I started sweating.
With a sharp turn at a crucial moment, I was
able to gain a vital lead and lose the beast.
Soon enough, it was no longer in my peripherals,
which was exactly how I liked it.
Then I ran into a gaggle of horrific creatures
that I can hardly even explain.
I was getting out of my stolen car to forage
for food in a nearby supermarket when suddenly
I was swarmed by what I can only describe
as a group of…
Human chicken monsters?
As stupid as they sound compared to the other
things I’ve faced, they were fast and incredibly
aggressive.
I was lucky to dodge a few of their brutal
charges and retaliate with a few blasts from
the shotgun, which at least bought me time
to escape - Even though I had to abandon my
car.
Easy come, easy go seem to be the rules of
this terrible new world.
Are they ever going to run out of horrible
beasts to throw at me?
Let’s see…
Over the eleven days that followed, between
periods of pure hiding, I actually had a first-hand
confrontation with agents of the SCP Foundation.
After the things I’ve seen, if I could punch
every single one of them so hard that they’d
never wake up, I’d do it, in a heartbeat.
It was their fault that all of this was happening,
and we’d never even know why.
Well, that’s not entirely true.
I was able to get myself some answers the
hard way…
I saw a helicopter circling above while I
was hiding behind a small collection of buildings.
They were shining a spotlight around, and
any time they saw a person walking out into
the open, they ruthlessly gunned them down.
When one person managed to duck away and run
through a narrow alley, the helicopter landed
and several men in tactical gear with assault
rifles stepped out.
When I recognized the SCP Foundation logo
on the side of the chopper, I felt my blood
rising to boil.
These were the ones who killed all these people.
As they began to disperse, I approached from
behind with murder in my eyes, and used the
shotgun to kill several of them.
Before any of them had a chance to retaliate,
I grabbed one of their fallen assault rifles
and fired back, killing or injuring them all.
The ones that were heavily injured were incapacitated,
but oddly, they didn’t seem to be in pain.
I aimed the gun at one of their heads and
told them to tell me why they were doing all
this.
That SCP Foundation foot soldier just smiled
and said, “You’re never going to know
how much we helped you.
But that’s okay.
We’re used to dying in the dark.
You’ll have to learn.”
So of course, I shot him in the head.
Hey, wouldn’t you?
I was better armed than ever, soon enough.
I had a new sidearm and an assault rifle,
along with a hell of a lot of ammo, from the
fallen SCP Foundation agents.
I took a little joy in the irony that the
SCP Foundation, the ones behind all this,
had provided me with the tools to defy their
reign of terror.
But none of that prepared me for that maniac
in the mask.
After getting a few days' rest in a basement
apartment I broke into, I emerged to continue
the journey.
I was maybe about fifty miles away from where
my ex and son were living, if they’d managed
to somehow stay put and survive all this time.
But when I left the basement apartment, something
was waiting for me.
It was a man wearing a white comedy mask,
dripping with this strange, black gunk, and
carrying a fire axe.
“Well hello there, good sir!” he said
with a laugh.
“How lovely to meet you.
It’s been a while since I’ve seen another
one like you.
You look like you’re carrying a lot of weight
on your shoulders, but don’t worry!
I can help with that!”
He gave a diabolical laugh and swung the axe
at my head.
I was able to narrowly dodge the blow and
return fire into center-mass with my rifle.
He seemed unfazed.
He just laughed and started charging forwards
with another swing from the axe.
Rather than shooting him again, and potentially
attracting some unwanted attention, I decided
to just run for it.
Every day, there are new surprises out here…
I made my way through a small town that had
been utterly decimated.
Homes and buildings were empty.
A huge stack of human corpses sat in the center
of town.
On top of the pile there stood a heavily tattooed
man, carrying a huge, black blade in each
hand.
He was clashing the blades together and calling
out, “This world has no worthy opponents
for the mighty Able!
Step forward and meet my blade, so at least
you can die with honor, you sad, timid little
sheep!”
I didn’t feel like dying with honor that
day, so I instead chose to discretely make
my way across the town, hoping that the “Mighty
Able” wouldn’t notice me.
And this paid off in the end, as I was able
to find an abandoned motorcycle, and high-tail
it out of there with all of my scavenged weaponry.
At long last, I was so damn close…
Just before day 90, that monstrous reptile
came back.
I swear to god, that monster is following
me, it’s more than just a coincidence now.
I was no more than twenty miles from my ex’s
place, driving at great speeds on my newly
purloined motorcycle when the giant, scaly
monster emerged from the side of the road
and knocked me off my bike.
If I didn’t think quickly and rely on my
training, I would have been killed - I’d
done two tours with the marine corps in Afghanistan
before being selected for defending the president,
a job that, technically, I’d failed miserably
at.
But those skills might be the only thing that
could let me stand a chance against this monster.
It reared up and tried to attack me again.
I used my stolen assault rifle to concentrate
fire on its eyes, trying to at least distract
it.
Its wounds healed quickly, and the pain of
the blasts doesn’t seem to have affected
it in the slightest.
But every time it lunges for me, I’m lucky
enough to have the room to dodge it.
This isn’t sustainable - I know that it
will have energy long after I tire.
What I need is a distraction so I can get
the hell out of here.
Then, an idea hits me!
I turn the gun on
the motorcycle’s fuel
tank and fire off a few rounds.
BOOM!
A nice, big, distracting fireball.
It buys me a few seconds, but that’s enough
to let me get away down a narrow alley and
make myself disappear.
All I can say is, I really hope I don’t
see that monster again.
Isn’t three times enough for one life?
Just when you think things can’t get any
stranger, you see something that almost breaks
your brain with its sheer surrealness.
While traveling through the town next to the
one where my ex and son live, I saw a heart.
Like a giant, beating heart, on spider legs
with a scorpion tail, destroying everything.
It was tearing buildings apart and somehow
setting people on fire with its caustic venom.
What on earth was the SCP Foundation that
it even knew about all these things?
I just kept walking, avoiding attention.
It’s all I could do.
It’s all anyone can do.
No one is saving a world like this, they’re
just avoiding getting killed in it.
Or helping someone they love to avoid getting
killed.
Speaking of, only one day off now.
Only one day off…
Day 100.
I arrived.
After all this hell, after seeing all this
nightmarish carnage that I’ll never be able
to unsee, I’ve reached the home of the ones
I love.
The ones I’ve been surviving for.
I walk up to the front door, step inside,
and find that the house is…
Empty.
Not a soul in sight.
For a moment, I’m terrified.
Had they
been killed?
There was no blood.
No bodies.
No sign of anything out of the ordinary.
That means that, like myself, maybe they were
on the move.
Maybe they were fleeing to find safety of
their own.
And if that was the case, I had a pretty good
feeling that I’d know exactly where they
are.
But my thoughts were interrupted by a loud
rumbling noise, coming from the house’s
basement…